ouf salut c'est salut le chat salut tout
le monde ça va super j'espère que toi
aussi les fêtes de Noël sont passées et
maintenant
on est au commentaire
du thérapie qui va commencer à l'instant
avec en vrai exactement Maxime Vacher La
Grave et toute enfin tous les joueurs du
top niveau c'est ça
on a vraiment quasiment tout le monde
qui est là on a du caresser donc du
Nakamura on a du mvl on a dû tout beau
scarwana bref tout le monde quasiment là
malheureusement on n'a pas à on aurait
bien aimé voir un autre français
mais il est pas là d'ailleurs je vais
vous montrer un petit peu si vous voulez
les joueurs qui sont présents je vais
vous montrer là la petite scène avec les
joueurs présents
et vous allez voir qu'on a du coup on a
quarantaine Nakamura n'est pas menacci
qui va d'ailleurs le match cette année
contre Ding pour championnat pour le
Championnat du Monde digne qui n'est pas
là digne qu'il est en train de se
préparer pour justement ce grand match
on a gritchouc on a guéri bon guéri tout
le monde le connaît et si Penko c'est la
jeune star montante russe exactement
forest qui est qui moi j'aime beaucoup
bonne soirée parce que il est toujours
très original dans ses ouvertures il a
toujours plein d'idées c'est un jeune
joueur aussi des Pays-Bas qui est à 2700
et lots un petit peu moins
on avait dit on a Douda mvl bien entendu
yoongi qui a été finaliste du coup je
crois des des champions de la Coupe du
Monde il y a quelques années on a brûlé
l'eau donc lui c'est un genre italien
qui a 2500 et quelques kg on a shanklan
et bien sûr mon petit favori
s'il vous plaît
qui
vient d'avoir
pour nous pour le Club de Cannes on a vu
en tournant ensemble par équipe et il
avait il avait 13 ans incroyable
et du coup bah moi je suis prêt et ça
exploit qui fait je suis super content
donc voilà le tournoi à bon là on a ce
jour là mais il n'y a pas que il y a
d'autres joueurs qui sont hyper forts
qui sont pas présentés dans cette pita
fiche
il y en a 200 ou 286 quelque chose comme
ça de joie
je pense 186 de 280 km en mètres à peu
près donc vous imaginez un petit peu les
les
le nom on va dire de de grand-mère on
n'a pas la place pour les mettre sur une
affiche mais en tout cas les joueurs
s'installent donc là on va vous montrer
un petit peu on va revenir sur la scène
la scène de base pendant que moi je
regarde parce que vous savez que les
caméras marche pas toutes on a des
petits problèmes de cave et du coup pour
l'instant je peux pas trop vous afficher
le truc
là j'ai la caméra de Douda qui marche
et c'est tout ce qui marche pour
l'instant après peut-être que
pour l'instant
je ne peux pas vous montrer le reste
donc bon
iranien je pense que vous en foutez un
petit peu comme nous du coup on va pas
mettre les caméras pour l'instant mais
voilà en tout cas moi je vois dans la
caméra je vous le dis que les joueurs
applaudissent ce qui veut dire que je
pense que la cérémonie d'ouverture est
en train de d'avoir lieu et que les
joueurs vont bientôt commencer la partie
donc pour les appariement là d'un
Carlsen voilà ça a commencé tu vois sur
la caméra que non ça a pas encore
commencé mais je vois que Carlson
va commencer il allait noir car elle
[Musique]
chaque chat
d'événement les organes ils aiment bien
jouer le premier coup toujours qu'elle
est blanc et donc ils ont joué le coup
de tarshake en contrecarne
et c'est le 4 c'est 2 4 qui a été joué
mais le pion était remis à sa place et
maintenant la partie va commencer dès
que ils auront fini de parler on voit
aussi maintenant que les joueurs
arrivent alors gars arrive à côté de de
Richard rappeur pour jouer 4 aussi voilà
alors moi je le vois sur le caméra enfin
je vois en fait je voulais le voir sur
la caméra de de James comme
[Musique]
je crois que ça marche que chez eux
il y en a plusieurs qui c'est
bienvenue en tout cas toutes celles et
ceux qui nous rejoignent et plus
fortement
depuis le début on a on a crié son Asus
space time explorer on a Barbie on a
Maximilien bracket Fatou qui va partir
[Musique]
et Gauvain malakil
bienvenue à tous
je vais te Polly avec toi
merci salut romain Gauvin salut à tous
bienvenue Bienvenue aujourd'hui c'est un
stream assez matinal pour ce début de
championnat tandis que les parties ont
commencé alors je vous propose
[Musique]
5 échec c'est la vente de Moscou
alors du coup attends
un message pas de souci t'inquiète
prends tout le temps ça lui pousseur de
bois
hop alors montant un peu fort
apparemment alors attends peut-être
baisser le gain
tac
salut JC
comparé à toi ambulance
j'ai baissé ton son est-ce que ça va
mieux dites moi ça va mieux allô allô
je répondais juste à
qui m'a écrit en privé mais un petit
problème de caméra les caméras qui qui
était censé
qui était censé qu'est-ce qu'il me dit
nickel merci pour vos retours les gars
et donc là les premiers coups de la
partie en tout cas qui se joue assez
rapidement
ils savent ce qu'ils font
et donc le premier adversaire de dmvl
covallevladislam
un jeune grand maître international de
28 ans biélorusse
biélorus ouais qui a été d'ailleurs en
on n'a pas vérifié mais qui était
qui était
qui était champion d'Europe je suis
quasi sûr ok on a pas vérifié mais je
mettrais ma main mais pas loin
de son pays en 2000-270
c'est un monstre attends juste là je
mets les caméras
OK
je suis en train de voir un peu pour les
caméras mais bon malheureusement
pour l'instant on est bon dans le
scénario Fatou
alors excusez-moi
avec pion 4 C4 contre la
contre la Sicilienne donc sur un choix
assez sympa la part de kobaf parce que
c'est très solide et puis là des options
de de
des options de pouvoir mettre la
pression avec le blanc et je solide tu
vois donc normalement c'est position là
les noirs n'ont pas vraiment de beaucoup
beaucoup de chance de tu vois
si de gains quand même en fait ça reste
solide pour le blanc et pour les Noirs
mais ce que je veux dire en fait par là
c'est que
tu vois MDL ce style où il veut un peu
[ __ ] la pagaille et c'est de gagner la
partie et c'est quand même dur avec les
Noirs faut vraiment essayer de de
justement compliqué la position
tellement solide que que c'est un petit
peu dur de trouver une solution pour
justement compliquer la pose OK
bon j'ai fait ce qu'on m'a dit et du
coup le camera
en même temps
et du coup pour les premiers échiquiers
on a on a Carsen et terre sac à Nakamura
Tabe n'est pas et en dessous la
[Musique]
en fait les tours C8 c'est de venir
inconvénients pour taper sur ton C4 ok
vulnérable souvent et par contre pour
ceux qui attend sur un cavaler à 4 il
peut y avoir un genre un problème avec
un Caval et bêtises c'est ça la petite
fourchette
donc c'est pas si simple c'est pas
comment ça va se passer mais le pion
c'est 4 reste quand même facilement
protégeable par B3 ou même
bouger le cavalier du B3 même du
cavalier 4 un coup qui peut pas mal
aussi c'est qu'elle va les prendre celui
de B5 pour essayer de d'échanger les
pions gagner un peu trop de la colonne A
avec la tour attaquer P4 plus tard c'est
standard cette position mais tu vois à
chaque échange de pièces qui aime
favorise un peu les blancs qui
bon c'est la rendre un tu vois tu
comptes mvl je sais pas vraiment s'il a
envie de partir à la grande conquête de
la partie et vos cowballev on va voir
en tout cas clairement mvl qui est un
des favoris quand même pour gagner le
temps
à noter aussi que mvl et les champions
du monde en ce moment sont pendant un
titre de de parties Blitz qui se jouera
donc à partir du 29 et 30
donc il va essayer de conserver son
titre en tout cas je sais pas ce que tu
en penses mais c'est quand même une
fierté de savoir que le champion du
monde est français quand même
qui nous avait régalé l'année dernière
j'ai un trou de mémoire là
fait partie des joueurs qui peuvent
éventuellement
faire quelque chose mais de la dire que
c'est le favori non il est pas favori
pour moi en tout cas c'est je le vois
comme ça pour moi
je te laisse meublé un petit peu
salut orang-outan bienvenue à vous les
gars
quel est le format du tournoi c'est un
tournoi Suisse Dark et Daniel
formation là pour aujourd'hui on a 5
rondes en partie rapide
des rondes d'une heure et demie donc
c'est des parties en 10 15 minutes plus
10 secondes par coup
quand j'ai regardé un petit peu les
autres parties où ça en est
donc là c'est le moment où forcément
des positions ça sort de l'ouverture ça
prend un petit peu plus le temps de
réfléchir ça joue moins tempo les coups
quand même justement c'est des moments
critiques des moments importants des
partis ou justement la moindre erreur
peut
changer la donne
un peu peur avec Amelia cadre ça me
faisait un peu peur parce qu'il est
parce que il va falloir
je sais pas comment tu vas dire
peut-être en effet dame C7 afin d'éviter
justement la fourchette mais
mais c'est déjà des coups de défense
parce que ouais mais en fait
qu'elle va les prendre en C6 plus
qu'elle va les baisers
et puis en plus une fois que le cavalier
une fois que le foot casse noir est
libéré ça ça protège en fait il veut
jouer il veut jouer cavalaca qui veut
jouer
alors attends juste on m'a demandé de
faire un truc pour le caméra
[Musique]
chez moi les caméras elles sont bien le
code on va voir si justement c'est le
scénario qui
qui va se faire sur cette partie ainsi
cavalier cavalier A4 va être joué
et bienvenue chez sloge Robin des Bois
bienvenue à vous
15 rue bienvenue
c'est la période on sait jamais évident
c'est l'hiver période des grippe des
angines
en tout cas j'espère que vous avez passé
de joyeuses fêtes de fin d'année
messieurs dames
alors merci pour vos retours
un petit peu les autres échiquier pour
voir un peu ce que ça donne
c'est vrai
c'est vrai et là on est sur la première
ronde matelanque on est sur la toute
première ronde
donc 5 aujourd'hui donc on est ensemble
à peu près jusqu'à 17h et du coup
B3 joué par
vladislave B3 solides
il prend son temps il construit la
pollutions
qui est très solide donc on va voir un
peu ce qui se passe mais je pense que
Sico Valley prend pas de risque je suis
pas sûr que MDL arrive à apprendre le
dessus dans cette partie en tout cas
on verra un peu
ce qu'il en est ce qui se passe
choisi de prendre son temps en tout cas
du monde je comprends que on n'est pas
envie de prendre trop de risques en tout
cas pour la première ronde
[Musique]
Moussa qui joue Moussa
ille
c'était
pour jouer parce que la nana il avait
pas joué on peut aller voir si vous
voulez un peu les français
pour être très très très bon en blitz et
Bullet en tout cas hyper dangereux et
qui ici avec les Blancs contre un joueur
à 24 50 un grand maître
unit T9 donc italienne avec hsg-5 qui
est thématique mais ça peut être
dangereux à jouer ouais
en tout cas pour lui
le Robin side je suis en train de voir
ça en même temps avec une caravane
et
je lui dis et en fait non ça marche pas
chez moi
ok du coup je vais changer
mais bon chez moi ça marche toujours pas
donc là vous avez vous avez Moussa qui
joue comme une pousse normale on va
aller voir rapidement si vous voulez un
petit Mase qui m'avait 44 40
mais bon rien de spécial je pense qu'on
va retourner un petit peu voir mvl c'est
quand même le français qu'on qu'on suit
et je pense pas grand chose pour
l'instant dans cette partie on va
remettre le bon côté et dans tous les
cas on vous tiendra au courant pour pour
les parties
alors du coup
il envoie B5 l'objectif du coup comme tu
disais tout à l'heure c'était justement
d'ouvrir de pouvoir ouvrir récupérer
avec le pion A5 pour pouvoir taper sur
sur le pion à deux des blancs
et ouvrir les colonnes en fait
yes alors attends
ça marche
et ben il y a pas fil rouge à sur ce sur
ce tournoi alors je ne sais pas pourquoi
je sais pas si on sur le c'est
d'ailleurs qu'on a pas d'enfant en tout
cas moi j'ai pas d'infos sur le fait que
le fil rouge ajout ou pas
je sais pas si Robin ça dans le chat a
des infos
salut à tous bienvenue
na qui a perdu alors je vais aller voir
en tout cas là d'accord
[Musique]
pour l'instant alors attends il a un peu
en plus pour l'instant
mais ok il va y avoir
ce mat là haut avec un G6 compliqué sur
lequel projet 6 mais
l'ordinateur annonce un truc à
incroyable pour les blancs en maison
on va voir en pratique
derrière le pion existe pas défendre les
deux cas en même temps
maintenant ce serait ce serait ce serait
perdant et franchement
tu bouges le pion F pour sortir
est-ce que ça marche
comme ça F5 ça a l'air un peu moche
quand même mais est-ce que ça tient pas
la position
après je sais pas ce qui se passe sur
ton bouge
apparemment ça a l'air d'être pas bien
mais en pratique avoir après bon même si
le droit vient ici sur la colonne la
colonne E ça va être très chaud quand
même pour les Noirs il va y avoir très
sûrement de la tactique et qui arrivera
toujours pas
j'ai que la 2 j'ai beau changer tout ce
qu'on veut et donc il y a une caméra
pour chaque table de joueur
non mais j'ai des caméras qui sont qui
bougent en fait dans la salle donc c'est
ça j'ai des caméras
sur d'étapes précises et puis moi je
suis moi ça marche pas du tout
ça marche pas quoi j'essaye toutes les
caméras la technologie malheureusement
c'est jamais infaillible
non mais là en plus tu vois j'ai un lien
quoi juste à changer le lien c'est pas
très compliqué chez moi c'est simple
mais
il veut pas
ici quand même dans la sauce et archi
mal au temps il reste que 4 minutes 30
secondes à la pendule même avec un
crémant et on sait que comme tu dis
Cyril c'est très fort joueur malgré le
fait qu'il n'est jamais été champion du
monde ni de beats ni de rapide ça reste
quand même un joueur redoutable
et là Mia rue des preuves malgré tout
il a fait j'ai essayé ce soir
Nakamura quand même il faut dire que
c'est un c'est un joueur qui qui
est très très bon en défense
ok extrêmement bon en défense donc il
faut encore le passé c'est pas encore
tout à fait c'est pas encore gagné
bon je sais pas quoi te dire
comme tu l'avais expliqué tout à l'heure
stouffe j'ai 6 ou projet 6
c'est c'est compliqué à tenir pour les
pour les noirs
on va voir comment ça continue
c'est parti
comment il s'en sort car française
[Musique]
généralement assez fermée où les blancs
prennent beaucoup d'espace de ce côté là
pendant que les Noirs en fait n'ont rien
mais une fois qu'il y a 5 arrive et ben
ça peut se retourner complètement en
faveur de l'adversaire parce que du coup
au final on le voit toujours au centre
c'est compliqué
donc après F5 on va se remettre à
comprendre peut-être pris ce cavalier
prend
et le cavalier qui peut après venir en 4
qui sera assez fort genre presque avaler
prend si cavalier vient pas en 4 enfin
c'est quand il prend un fils par exemple
je fais ça me prend un V6 et puis un
jour je continuerai avec peut-être 5
peut-être même ouvrir la position sans
que le noir blanc n'a pas vraiment
d'abris tu vois mais oui
pas forcément envisageable ici non ça va
être chaud c'est trop ouvert et petit
rock ça sera un coup mais bon j'ai quand
même jouer H4
j'aurais quand même G5 qui sera un coup
possible donc avec profil vient d'être
joué par par Carcen ici
et qui a déjà une belle position
cavalier E5 qui recaraient le 4 donc
c'est pas trop trop jouable
[Musique]
peut-être laisser comme ça cavalier ici
et proposer autre chose pour petit mais
bon je pense que les
Noirs
ils vont essayer d'attaquer comme ça
pas simple la sous pression sous
pression les blancs là je suis retourné
voir la partie des MELS
à chaque fois il me remette le côté le
côté des blancs
donc là je veux 5 donc il a réussi un
peu s'activer mais la position est
encore complètement égale ici ici on
peut s'attendre à un coup comme un T3 H1
pour préparer préparer du cavalier 5
avec avec les Blancs
les deux pièces mineures et après j'ai
deux contre un ici voilà donc bon je
pense que pas grand chose
B4 des Noirs ça va être un coup normal
ici qui va arriver un jour
parce que l'idée en fait de Beckett
c'est que je fixais la structure donc
il peut être c'est ça pour l'instant il
est protégé une fois mais faut faire
attention
de ce pion qui pourrait une faiblesse
comme tu le dis mais Ben j'aurai à deux
qui sera aussi une faiblesse et qui
pourra pas avancer
je vous rappelle que si on pousse à
quatre en passant et le 5 qui était
juste par mvl à retiens c'est un coup
hyper intéressant donc c'est un coup qui
qu'on ne joue jamais jamais jamais dans
les positions keto quand le foot enfermé
mais ici il y a quand même une exception
c'est que voilà on est toujours qu'on
joue pas le 5 enfin on peut jouer au
sein seulement si derrière je suis en
mesure de pouvoir j'ai de dessins pour
ouvrir la position si des cinq n'est pas
possible et ben je ne joue pas je ne
joue pas le 5 c'est la règle donc il a
joué 5 parce qu'il a vu qu'il pouvait
les scènes derrière donc ça qu'on peut
on peut imaginer comme il faut 3 avec
dessin qui ailles et après des 5 bah
écoute j'ai l'impression que
que
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que les que les noirs
sont plutôt bien
mais est-ce que justement ah oui ok donc
des cinq qualités
[Musique]
du coup les blancs pouvoir enfin les
enfants
mais je pense qu'il a eu peur de de P4
qui avait des bouées
peut-être que B4 était le coup qui
permettait d'empêcher beaucoup B4 une
possibilité mais B4 c'est donc un plein
de cases comme un casque C4 tout ça donc
t'as pas forcément envie de jouer 4 donc
en tout cas t'es pas un choix facile ici
pour pour Coval F
qui du coup on a juste ça il y a des
échanges et du coup voilà qui joue quand
même pour pour la nuit ici un échange
toutes les pièces et il a raison parce
qu'il commence à être un peu moins bien
là il a un poil moins bien avec les avec
les Noirs donc du coup
encore encore faut-il terminer ou
concrétiser
position parce que là ça reste
ça il y a de moins en moins de pièces
sur l'échiquier
[Musique]
bienvenue à toutes celles et ceux qui
nous rejoignent bienvenue à toutes et à
tous
et pour la partie que contre Naka donc
quand j'ai 6 ça a été joué
suivi de
fouger 5
donc il a pas récupéré le
four G6
justement à cause de la variante qu'on
avait vu
projet 6 qui a été joué de la part de
des blancs et qui répond par fou fou
j'ai 5 s'il prenait il y avait la il y
avait tout en prison
jouets et là du coup bah il faut
sûrement je 6 qu'elle va les prendre
puis on prend et là le roi il est
complètement ouvert chez chez laka et
c'est chaud mais bon c'est pas fini
encore ça foutu le reposer donc tu vois
tu tu mets une bien manger 7 et de tenir
un peu la pollution est clairement
favorable au blanc il va être embêter il
y a B7 en prises également
une pièce devant
c'est pas un chariot franchement
il est très très fort aussi en but c'est
rapide je me souviens c'était marrant
parce qu'on avait joué ce soir tu sais
et OK et en fait toute la semaine on
était quand même 7 au 8 entre 2004 et
2300 hello ensuite
et quasiment tous envie et il a pas
parlé d'une seule partie de la semaine
voilà ok ah ouais donc
tu vois bon on n'est pas des génies mais
on se bat quoi
niveau quand même
une ou deux mais
pas plus
il va devoir encore travailler pour la
gagner mais bon ça va être dur pour pour
la tenir aussi quoi je pense que si il
fait pas d'impact
aussi j'ai vu ta vidéo aussi avec avec
un VL c'était classe
en tout cas
OK
alors du coup on va remettre encore le
côté noir
et du coup mvl qui gagne un petit peu il
a un peu mieux je pense alors tu vois la
cavalier
qui veut l'autre en Détroit pour taper
du coup le pion B4
qui était faible comme tu l'avais tu
l'avais signé là au début
la position blanche solidaire malgré
tout on voit que les Noirs au centre
enfin peu plus actif mais bon je suis
pas sûr qu'on arrive vraiment à tirer un
avantage ici pas simple du tout en
cavalier F4 qui avait l'air Détroit
sûrement pour échanger les pièces après
cavalier D3 des blancs j'ai l'impression
que les pièces noires sont sont vouées à
la protection
[Musique]
ne serait pas impossible
parce que la pollution malheur a assez
assez égal et est-ce que vraiment les
gens ont envie de prendre des risques
ici c'est pas sûr mais non c'est clair
c'est la ronde un
prévoir si on peut jouer cavaluer 6 pour
venir en a des cadres
donc la cadence oui c'est 15 + 10 là
un petit peu comment comment il joue
parce que si tu prends ici tout
simplement
qui est intéressant
OK
même pas d'âme fin possible pour les
blancs en plus tu manges là je prends là
et maintenant du coup j'ai accès à la
case ici
pour voir s'il aura blanc arrive en C4
rapidement mais
donc c'est assez compliqué mais en tout
cas je pense qu'amvl il peut il peut
essayer de de pousser un peu la position
mais le cavalier dessin cavalier F4
reste quand même une option envisageable
enfin nul je pense mvl a envie de se
mettre la pression dans la première
partie tu vois si votre champion du
monde il faut commencer à marquer des
points quoi
au fur et à mesure de l'avancée du
tournoi les joueurs prennent plus de
risques sont plus prudents en début de
tournoi comment comment ça se passe dans
la tête justement d'un
jouet ben en fait c'est ça dépend de ton
tournoi quoi et je te l'attente tu vois
là tu vois mvl champion du monde de
partir de partie Blitz
on peut clairement imaginer qu'il ait
envie de qu'il a envie de gagner quoi
forcément
donc il va tout faire pour gagner après
c'est long les gars 13 parties de 15 +
et à rendre du jean 26 50 quoi
fort contre faible donc imaginez un
petit peu le niveau de tournant que ça
va que ça demande quoi donc en fait
voilà on sait pas ça ça dépend de tout
ça il peut y avoir un peu de Tilt
j'avais vu il y avait une année il y
avait un de scène qui avait joué qui
avait joué c'était en rapide
il avait il avait perdu la première
partie
contre un petit train 2005-2006
et donc ça peut arriver tu vois et la
ronde 2 il avait joué en 2300 et il
avait tenté le match
en mode troll tilt et il a perdu la
partie il a perdu la partie produit donc
il a commencé avec avec 0 sur 2 et au
final il a quand même fait un
podium je pense mais bon il a commencé
les heures en sorte de malheureusement
c'est mal parti pour lui mais du coup tu
vois lui qui veut clairement pour être
champion du monde bah il avait un peu
tilté quoi
personne n'est à l'abri après mvl bah il
joue enfin s'il fait un excellent il
peut être champion en tout cas il a le
talent pour et c'est
vraiment son ambition quoi il veut être
champion quoi bah oui mais après ok le
temps est tellement fort qu'on va voir
un peu comment ça se passe mais les
joueurs vont essayer de prendre tout le
risque tu vois la mvl bah il pousse un
peu il pousse il pousse il a pas pris
l'avion
voilà et après on peut suicider tu vois
si c'est nul mais du coup ouais c'est
long il prend ils prennent les risques
il essaie de prendre un peu les
opportunités qui leur sont proposées et
puis ils font ce qu'ils peuvent quoi
voilà et puis ouais c'est ce qu'on se
disait hier c'est un tournoi extrêmement
fort en fait où tous les joueurs pour
participer ont forcément eu 2550 vélos
minimum dans les 12 derniers mois donc
c'est vraiment un tournoi
si nous on pouvait du monde ce serait
pas forcément sur place du monde tu vois
parce que ben on a pas le niveau quoi
clairement je veux dire c'est
réservérant à l'élite tu as un peu moins
de 300 joueurs vous imaginez un tournoi
comme ça moi j'aurais vrai de ouf
d'aller participer et parce que c'est
tellement tellement bien quoi tu vois tu
as un du monde avec karsent avec
Nakamura
bah tu es avec le top monde quoi voilà
et du coup tu as trop y aller mais du
coup si moi j'ai envie d'y aller
j'imagine que plein d'autres gens
veulent y aller aussi donc c'est un peu
normal qu'ils ouvrent pas la porte à
tout le monde tu vois que tu puisses pas
y aller
à sauver comme ça donc du coup
c'est normal
de dire champion des Canaries tu pourras
bah oui il faut il faut aussi je le suis
pas d'ailleurs
je le suis encore pas encore alors là je
suis champion de mon île ok
par contre on commence par là
mais après le canari j'ai fait une
deuxième j'ai fait un mauvais endroit
c'est un truc
et ensuite
j'ai fait enfin des Canaries de plus
rapide que j'ai pas pu faire
malheureusement j'étais en déplacement
en France ce weekend là donc non non
j'ai pas pu les faire donc je suis pas
champion de canari nylan
mais bon
et en vrai si tout le monde enfin si
vraiment une qualification pour pour
aller là-bas il y aura quand même du
monde je pense qu'elle arrive parce que
en vrai au niveau des licenciés et des
joueurs qui jouent pour les Canaries il
y a quand même des joueurs qui sont pas
mauvais
il y a beaucoup il y a beaucoup de jours
d'échecs quand même là-bas pas tant que
ça mais il y a des gens qui sont pas
mauvais il y a des il y a quelques
regards il y a deux camps et il y a
plusieurs amis et d'ailleurs on a un et
demi qui est sur le chat
qui est qui est l'essentiel
OK et voilà
[Musique]
d'ailleurs ce jour-là il pourrait
quasiment participer au championnat du
monde
[Musique]
50 points pour pas pour pouvoir
participer
à ce tournoi mais 50 points 50 points du
coup
en rapide
2506 ou le client quoi
bon il a quand même fait 9 sur 9
[Musique]
automatiquement un perfect un perfect en
tong voilà c'est masterclass
j'ai validé j'ai validé franchement et
aussi oui donc pour ce tournoi là il
faut détenir le type de champion
national aussi donc en classique en
classique en rapide ou en beats
donc faut vraiment faire partie du top
du top de son pays pour justement avoir
une chance et la possibilité de
participer à ce moment-là
du coup c'est assez cool du coup barbix
il a 50 points à peu près un de pouvoir
participer à ce tournoi mais bon il
serait dans la rue
mais du coup c'est ce serait mais ce
serait faisable quoi ce serait jouable
assez c'est quand même à la portée de
certaines personnes comme ça ça serait
trop bien quoi après ça peut être long
quand tu es parti mais ce serait juste
génial quoi le tournoi il
a il se déroule à
almatis j'ai pas de bêtises c'est
au Kazakhstan
la ville c'est dans ce palmatie je me
trompe peut-être
je peux
je suis retourné voir vite fait aussi un
petit peu la partie de partie du carreau
et
c'est vraiment compliqué pour lui là
mais bon
quand même plus limiter la casse merci
tu lui transmettras aussi mes vœux de
bonheur
mais avec toi ça va être compliqué
du coup non MDL c'est c'est solide quand
même
des chances de guerre tu vois qu'il y
avait des trois il y a des trous de
partout
et
et tu vois il reste plus qu'une limite
elle a pendule pour pour que Valve notre
3 minutes 30
et ça m'est déjà apprécié autant en plus
de ça clairement il y a moyen de de
mettre la pression en tout cas ça c'est
clair ça c'est clair
oui le tournoi se déroule à almati au
Kazakhstan c'est des questions
pour lui je suis passé voir tout à
l'heure et
il a pas rendu la tâche facile à faire
quand même donc comme tu disais hyper
fort en défense
c'est chaud c'est chaud en tout cas il
ne viendra pas mais c'est chaud
noir rase un peu de voyou
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il
pourquoi est-ce que c'est pas bien
ça met gagnant pour les pour les Noirs
enfin le coup le coup gagnant
c'est pas le coup gagnant parce que
complètement
six voix
super quoi OK et pourquoi dame 8 du coup
c'est juste compréhensible peut-être
qu'il voulait faire
échec voilà il faut F4 d'un point il y a
alors c'est rien c'est compliqué ok
ouais mais bon
quand même fou c'est ça qui aussi
bon en fait voilà faut c'est 5 et
peut-être vu d'un échec ici voilà tu
vois là 7 sécurise
c'est vrai après H6 peut-être Rohff mais
bon après le roi se retrouve dans
le roi comme ça
ce qui va ce qui va essayer de voir en
fait c'est que du coup il y a des
problèmes sur la première rangée tu vois
et du coup peut-être un F6 d'un point F6
et dame là-haut ça peut être sympa à
voir par exemple regarde F6 et
d'un proche
il y a quand même des échecs dangereux
pour les Noirs quoi du coup
ouais en tout cas c'est chaud mais je
pense qu'il va je pense qu'il a dû enfin
rage 7 je pense qu'il a quand même du
MP2 oui parce que je pense qu'il a dû
voir ça
et du coup et du coup ici F6
ils sont un point F6 à voir ce qui se
passe j'ai plein d'échecs j'ai d'autres
aussi à chaque fois directement qui
empêche du coup Cavaillon
et après
j'ai du cavalier 3
[Musique]
j'ai pas mal de d'échecs possibles sur
cavalier chèque voilà
je sais pas si j'ai envie
dans le cavalier protégé par le fou ok
ouais en tout cas ça a l'air c'est l'air
compliqué donc un mec qui prend bien son
temps il reste à la pendule une minute
une minute pour 14 secondes
plus simple je suis pas sûr ah 20
minutes
ça fait peur quand même franchement
fourchette ça ferait mal ouais
tu vois
d'un point M6
un peu de partout tu vois il y a dames
c'est un qui qui est jouable et ça a
l'air compliqué alors cavaler là
[Musique]
par exemple tu vois
on va où voilà
en vrai ça a l'air ça a l'air chaud
ça a l'air ça a l'air chaud
que ça ça je crois qu'il y a plus de
chaque après
et
ici enfin deux qui va arriver mais après
parce que ça suffit parce que le
cavalcade est défendu par la dame la
dame noire va partir ici quand même la
menace de Mathis
ok c'est la partie ok il est fou OK
voilà
parce qu'en fait OK et avoir ces deux
donc là j'ai chèque la France ça va ça
va très pétition pour faire nul mais
juste sur Internet
tout de suite pourquoi pas
parce qu'il y a dans
qui gagne oups
ça répète rapidement ça va pas vite mais
sur ça en gros ça j'ai échec qui fait
mat sur ça j'ai maths
comme ça oups
se jouent donc
une fois que ce sera ils ont fait nul on
pourra on pourra modifier on pourra
changer
on pourrait check
mais là il y avait il y avait un gars en
fait donc là du coup ça va faire nul et
nulle forcer donc on va lève qui avait
sans doute tout ça avant de manger 6
toute façon pas trop le choix dans cette
position il devait prendre la fin il
devait manger F6 parce que comme chanson
qui n'a pas bougé encore je pense que
voilà trop cette annoncé
sur cavaler des liens ici j'avais fou F4
échec en gros sur sur un point F4 j'ai
fourchette entre le roi et la dame
et du coup si du coup roi bouge bah j'ai
échec
suivi d'un petit matelas donc voilà
chaud donc voilà un résultat logique nul
avec les noirs et comme tu dis noir
en changeant d'Europe bon c'est pas un
plot hein donc résultat assez logique
d'ailleurs je t'ai besoin d'une partie
que c'était un truc qui avait l'air
qui moi me semblait
français avec avec Jules qui qui aimait
quand même
une petite pression là il y a un pion de
plus pour les noirs avec une tour qui
peut aller manger le pion G2 ça reste
sur pas simple du tout parce que on voit
que le cavalier [ __ ] d'effondre le
pion comme ça le roi qui peut s'activer
H4
pour défendre ce petit pion là
et précédemment j'ai des pions les pions
noirs pas simple du tout ah mais vu elle
est blanche excusez-moi Julie du coup un
peu en PLS là
quoique est-ce que si il mange le pion
ici il arrive à pousser
en fait cavalier prend pour prendre F5
après il y a le pion a quand même qui
et puis le roi blanc va finir par manger
des trois donc
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas été voir Mazet
encore
OK
donc il a mangé comme ça ok on va
prendre le roi donc là du coup je pense
que Julie peut il peut la pousser un
petit peu
il peut la pousser un peu relais 5 à
pousser le pur h et j'aime bien les
blancs en fait parce que toi le roi
blanc est actif
parce que la tour elle est pas derrière
elle est sur le côté
je le vois gagner
donc que nous fait notre petit Mazo il
est noir il y a une pièce nette de plus
il va gagner ça devrait bien se passer
ouais ils vont à 23 73 qui joue un petit
stouf
avec une pièce de plus ok ça a gagné mes
cavaliers fcg4 m'attendait un
donc belle partie du capitaine Mazet
voir un peu comment il a gagné la pièce
alors cavale F5 les blancs qui ont
essayé de faire un peu de la magie on
voit ça c'est un peu bizarre le
placement des pièces blanches quand même
depuis le début de partie
c'est un peu space
alors que les Noirs ont quand même faire
un super développement de pièces vous
voyez les Noirs les pièces sont bien
placées
et un problème sur le fou qui était
cloué j'aurais pu le défendre mais il y
avait
le fou
ça ça pièce de plus et après bah c'est
juste terminé
à ce niveau-là c'est une pièce d'avance
c'est déjà trop
ça fait déjà un moment qu'il aurait pu
abandonné le mec avec avec les Blancs
donc voilà
je crois qu'il a il a il a ça fait nul
si je dis pas de bêtises
attends si je suis bien un jour sur le
sur le site
ah non ça joue attends
chez moi je sais pas si ça
de mon côté ils ont plus de temps les
deux joueurs
un petit peu OK dans sa chambre encore
et je lui fais quoi
gagner du temps à gagner
qui sont qui s'imposent quand même en
général visite qui gagne du bof qui
gagne
aussi
qui a gagné aussi
donc manière générale quand même les
favoris
favorisent s'impose
dans cette première ronde en tout cas
après ça va ça va ça va se jouer un peu
sur les prochaines aussi ouais donc là
du coup on a on a quand même bon
Jules qui a qui a tout bien passé contre
un seul ça c'est gagnant facilement je
pense
même si la tour se sacrifie je crois sur
le Tour d'ailleurs c'est ça depuis on
passé lié et déduire
donc mvl il a fait nul mais parti normal
Alrick
[Musique]
c'est nul avec les Noirs en vrai bon
résultat
et donc tu avais raison pour la partie
du Moussa reste tout fin oui non mais ça
se voyait en fait
si tu veux si tu veux les
la Tour Blanche était active et puis on
passait était actif aussi le roi le roi
blanc aussi tu compares le roi blanc
actif ici contre le roi noir là-bas qui
a pas bougé c'était clair que c'était
une belle tête pour Jules en plus en
pratique en pratique hyper compliqué
pour les Noirs
s'il a abandonné mais je pense que je
pense que oui
il y a 13 parties en tout il y aura cinq
aujourd'hui
et si vous voyez donc pour les blancs
c'est une dame imparable
à part Jules mvl Mazet
en tout cas moi j'ai pas vu de français
non je crois que c'est je crois que
c'est mais je crois qu'il y en a pas
d'autres
donc j'ai on aurait pu en avoir d'autres
peut-être mais
[Musique]
pour ce tournoi là alors c'est assez
bizarre je sais pas du tout pourquoi
dommage qu'on n'est pas qu'on n'est pas
fier
j'imagine que fille Rose prépare pour
pour les tournois en partie lente
vu que le Blitz pense à l'intéresse pas
trop
on peut la repartir pendant ce temps-là
pendant que pendant que
c'est pas simple du coup
j'ai rien dit j'ai rien dit
tout F4 Tour Eiffel
et c'est assez curieux cette position
parce que tu as l'impression que les
Noirs n'arrivent pas à progresser même
si on échange les toits cavaliers ici
j'ai pas de C5 P6 c'est dur à faire et
donc il y aura 600 là
il est trop fort en fait et oui
pour la pièce donc c'est pas une pièce
gratuite 100%
donc
je pense ça répète les couleurs
ici donc il faut le défendre avec ton G7
Tour Eiffel
et tout rêve c'est ce qui va manger le
pion ouais c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable
c'est assez incroyable
mais je me demande comment comment
est-ce que on peut on peut montrer vite
fait un petit peu comment s'est déroulée
la partie pour arriver à cette position
là ouais on peut aller voir un petit
coup on peut aller voir donc ça c'est
une position assez standard
j'ai 5 OK
pour que je contrôle le four F5
généralement généralement en fait tu
vois ça c'est une position avec les
noirs avec C6 et F5 ça c'est une on va
dire une une gamme tranquille et
foie F4 et c'est 5 c'est les meilleurs
de jouer en fait tu joues sur le casque
etc et tu as le fluctor BK
et en fait du coup quand le centre est
fermé comme ça les noirs peuvent se
permettre de pouvoir ouvrir avec G5 F1
quand le purge dans ces quatre c'est
quand même beaucoup plus compliqué parce
que j'ai pas ouvrir la position sachant
que je peux à tout moment casser la
structure et ouvrir le centre
et au final on a une position à base un
petit peu de Stonewall mur de pierre
donc avalerampillon OK et maintenant il
joue F4 donc c'est un jeu assez actif
donc
et je pense que il doit faire en plus
5 F3 en tout cas c'est assez standard de
position pour casser le centre justement
donc il y a eu ici F4 directement le fou
il est il est perdu tu vois
la pièce ah oui
mais il a pas forcément envie de donner
son full casse noir comme ça et du coup
il a repris ce prises il a essayé FK
donc il a donné une pièce mais en
échange de plein de pions tu vois il a
mangé quand même un peu de central un
pion sur la colonne G qui lui ouvre la
colonne h c'est chaud ouais donc il y a
quand même il y a quand même une petite
compensation pour la pièce quand même
j'ai damage 5 la diagonale j'ai quand
même
mais après en pratique c'est quand même
mieux pour les pour les blancs mais pour
les Noirs pardon mais bon c'est du Blitz
je vous rappelle enfin c'est du rapide
il faut être précis
dans un temps limité c'est pas facile
et puis tout ce qui aime bien défendu
tout ça mais les blancs autour des
bonnes cases soit ils ont le centre une
position très solide
et la pièce marchait pas tu vois il y a
eu cavalier F5 servant du petit clouage
qui a sur le diagonal
et voilà quoi
donc prise prise et puis on est arrivé
dans cette position quoi donc tu vois le
fou il est mauvais des pièces
jouent pas à 5 qui est bien joué qui
bloque un peu la structure adverse
et puis ça
tourne et ça fait ça fait nul du coup
exactement voilà donc non intéressant
compliqué pas clair donc là on a du coup
encore une partie en jeu c'est Salem
qui a des blancs
on a un petit lag par rapport au
résultat oui il y a un petit laps de
temps parce que là on a aussi on a aussi
là on a quand même pétrole contre
abdelker je ne connais pas ça joue
encore celle-là ok donc cette partie qui
joue encore
qui
prend ce qui va se passer ici
donc normalement c'est nul même si les
blancs arrivent à manger le pion ça va
faire nul car ça il a fait nul ça fait
il a gagné
[Musique]
la partie de Bruno qui joue encore Bruno
c'est notre italien
ça m'a l'air un peu difficile
parce que le roi va arriver à passer à
se cacher mais madame de vin changer
d'arme et
c'est possible
rien de temps qui perd à 2002 waouh
sérieux
ça j'ai pas vu tous les résultats
malheureusement
il a l'air pas bien
es pour moi s'il est maître Philippe
[Musique]
parce qu'il est quand même croître je
pense pas que sa jambon son pays
peut-être qu'il a été invité aussi donc
parce qu'on disait justement donc il
fallait avoir 2550 et l'eau les 12
derniers mois il fallait être champion
nationale mais il faut aussi faire c'est
possible qu'il fasse partie des 10
invités de la fille de ou je crois 15
invités et 15 invités et donc après
peut-être que c'est un jeune qui qui tu
vois on connaît pas peut-être que
peut-être que c'est un jeune peut-être
qu'il est aussi un gros élan
on sait pas on sait pas parce que c'est
possible
mais ouais ça peut être un jeune de
12-13 ans on n'en sait rien
et du coup je pense qu'il y aura un peu
de retard pour la ronde 2 parce que
c'est prévu à 11h15 dans 10 minutes il y
a encore deux parties enfin plusieurs
parties en jeu je sais pas ce qu'on
arrivera à voir
est-ce que en ce qui concerne les
caméras des joueurs on a toujours que ça
on m'a dit de faire un essai à la pose
donc enfin une pause tout à l'heure là
qui marchent pas et du coup on m'a
demandé de faire de faire autre chose
maintenant je peux même le faire ici
je vais le faire là si tu veux
[Musique]
je le fais en même temps
ok donc je vais faire ça
salut root comment ça va les gars
bienvenue toutes celles et ceux qui nous
rejoignent
et oui ça a commencé à 10h la première
ronde donc là on arrive sur la fin de la
dernière de la première route pardon et
il y en a 5 aujourd'hui on est ensemble
à peu près jusqu'à 17 heures
il y a des Allemands dans le tournoi
bénitos probablement
il y a tous les tous les jeunes
toute l'équipe
tous les génies de leur pays quoi
est-ce que ça marche ça
ah oui donc ouais darda Daniel bah tu
pars dubaf en effet
le jeune belge
c'est vrai
donc sur la partie là de d'Ariane tari
je sais pas ce qui non je pense que ça
se terminait parce que c'est terminé
ouais ça bouge plus je pense que je
pense que
je pense qu'il a dû abandonné
je sais pas
franchement
après la technologie quand ça veut pas
ça veut pas
je continue à faire je crée des
des trucs
les liens si vous voulez
les liens ne marchent pas chez moi
et du coup on m'a demandé de recréer les
liens
ce que je fais
mais
de toute façon
c'est le premier jour c'est normal non
mais juste la caméra marche pas
ça malheureusement je
et donc la deuxième ronde qui va
commencer de d'ici quelques minutes
je vais voir si on a on a les appareils
Man ou pas pour la deuxième ronde
non je pense pas
quand on est parti
rien ne marche chez moi
[Musique]
et puis après je pense qu'on va partir
ma petite pause de toute façon parce que
attends
[Musique]
une autre partie qui est en train de se
jouer c'est pas trop chiant contre
abdelker
ton faux contre torption donc même si je
perds la peur c'est nul
mais par contre la finale elle est pas
simple le mec avec parce que c'est nul
mais c'est il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
résultats impossible en fait il y a
beaucoup de gens qui perdent ces
finalement qui est censé être nul mais
simple en pratique à tenir en tout cas
pas simple du tout genre de final ou la
moindre imprécision peut
être très très dur c'est extrêmement dur
franchement à ce niveau là j'ai envie de
dire que si le trosion il prend le pion
il a quasiment gagné j'ai envie de dire
ok c'est un grand pas en tout cas par la
victoire parce que c'est nul mais en
pratique c'est tellement dur surtout que
le jour en face il a 2270 bon c'est un
bon joueur mais
pratique c'est tellement dur à tenir
cette position que à ce niveau là je
suis patient parce qu'il y a une
pression tu joues quand même 6-20
ok bon ça
vous dit on va faire un petit pause de 5
minutes
allez la partie de son la prochaine
partie commencera à 15 normalement là il
va y avoir un délai il va avoir une une
du retard par rapport à ce que tu as un
morceau au début parce que encore une
partie en cours et je pense que les
joueurs enfin les organes vont vouloir
faire souffler un peu les joueurs entre
les parties donc on fait une petite
pause de 5 minutes et on revient tout de
suite donc restez parmi nous ne partez
pas je vous dis à tout de suite à tout
de suite les amis on se retrouve pour la
room 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de Maxime pour cette première ronde et
une victoire de Richard apporte et de
Mazet
ouais que pour nos Français en tout cas
pour cette première ronde
même si
il a un an un peu c'est un genre
hongrois voilà mais en France on a
gagné on a on a masé et on a une VL qui
a fait nul au fond du et
du coup du coup voilà donc là les
caméras sont apparues donc magnifique
oui en fait Samy j'ai compris le
problème et j'ai réussi à régler le
problème tout seul comme un grand un
génie de l'informatique
c'est un problème
[Musique]
un bruit de fond chelou
je règle un problème j'en ai un autre
qui arrive c'est génial c'est génial
j'ai le
ah ça y est ça y est c'est moi qui ai
fait un petit bug donc
[Musique]
et donc du coup du coup voilà
alors le problème 5 minutes je vais dire
ce que c'était
le problème c'était qu'en fait tu sais
quand tu copies le lien pour avoir les
caméras bah moi j'étais copier-coller
enfin tu vois je suis pas débile quoi
mais en fait il y a un espace tu sais
quand tu copies un lien tu as toujours
un espace de un caractère juste derrière
en fait et du coup il fait que je
supprime l'espace du caractère voilà
maintenant ça marche c'est juste
bon en tout cas les caméras marche tout
va bien salut aslo
[Rires]
[Musique]
donc après j'ai quand même assez faire
plein de trucs pour les caméras mais
rien ne marcher en tout cas en tout cas
bon content qu'on est les caméras que ça
marche donc là on a la salle de jeux
vous voyez les les filles qui sont
prêtes à
commencer les parties on n'a pas encore
je crois les appareils
j'ai pas encore l'appareil mais en tout
cas de mon côté je sais pas
du coup je suis pas débile
non mais en fait tu sais quand tu copies
colle un lien
enfin je sais pas censé rajouter quelque
chose à côté quoi voilà
donc voilà merci pour ton lien classe
parce que les appartements sont sortis
en fait mais ne sont pas encore rentrés
en fait results
[Musique]
on a masé qui joue table 8 avec les
Blancs contre artemief on a moussaar qui
a des Noirs contre
Ivic donc Ivic il est un peu sous classé
là on voit 2489 en rapide alors Kevin
qui a quand même plus de 2006 en l'an
donc c'est une grosse partie pour pour
Jules et mvl ou mvl qui continue contre
un genre très fort
mdr qui aura des blancs qui vont tabac
Tabeille tabac Tabe qui qui a fait nul
contre Nakamura c'est la grosse partie
où il y avait le G6 ou prend les 6 là
donc bah c'est ce jour-là et donc c'est
mvl qui aura les plans cette fois-ci
contre tabac tabac donc c'est maintenant
faisons nul qui était un résultat quand
même assez logique mais bon tu vois et
ben il joue encore un grand maître à 26
ok ouais donc vraiment dans les
apparisants pour ce début de tournoi
c'est pas c'est pas simple pour elle
très fort quand tu en plus là dernière
étape tournoi tu as 89 c'est Andrew Tang
je sais pas si tu connais en tout temps
euh thé vert alors non non en route
c'est une des stars américaines de
Bullet un des meilleurs joueurs de
Bullet sur la planète un kilomètre qui a
25 50 mais
en Bullet sur tous les sites c'est un
joueur hyper dangereux comment il
s'appelle sur les autres sites ou même
sûrement même sur pièces com numéro 1
Bullet sur litchi
avec avec firou et tout c'est c'est
la meilleure genre quoi et donc une
machine
et pourtant et pourtant en Bullet il a
3003 enfin c'est c'est un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde quoi et là
après bon le Lot et le Bullet c'est
vraiment non de jeux totalement et puis
c'est la honte de mais ça mais c'est
juste pour montrer à quel point le
niveau tournoi et monstrueux quoi c'est
juste pour ça que je faisais cette
petite parenthèse mais elle va le niveau
il est doucement quand tu vois ton la
comme ça ça demande rien tu as quasiment
que des gens qui traits quasiment que
d'ailleurs mettre il y a que ça on a vu
que
on était tombé là sur la partie d'un
maître fit de là tout à l'heure ouais
c'est c'est au minimum et dans tous les
cas ouais c'est tournoi très très fermé
réservé justement elle est vite
et on voit que quand scène joue contre
Hansen donc Hansen c'est le numéro 1
du Canada et streamer aussi sur chessbra
donc d'ailleurs petite vidéo sur Youtube
où j'ai piégé un de ces dans une
carotane piège d'ouverture contre
Eric Hansen lors d'un d'une Ariana Kings
là dans la dernière arène que tu as
faite non c'était il y a peut-être un
mois un truc comme ça mais
Fatou ml déjà il faut pas tout elle elle
prenne l'avion et qu'elle se dépêche
pour arriver pour arriver au Kazakhstan
ça les routes bienvenue à toi bienvenue
à tous les gars je n'ai pas beaucoup
joué
mais quelquefois
mais j'ai pas beaucoup joué
l'année prochaine je pense pas que je
gagne 250 points
c'est un peu trop pour moi tu as
beaucoup de tournois de prévu là pour
pendant cette saison là pour cette année
non juste un avec toi
ah oui c'est vrai
on va on va jouer on va jouer
un petit équipe
sympa et c'est pas touche comment
va-t-il
bienvenue à tous
donc la ronde 2 qui devrait démarrer
en tout cas
qui viennent d'être postées
[Musique]
attends non c'est le résultat
que ça va pas passer le français
et donc là pour les premiers échiquiers
il y a Hansen
carlsena Marty Marty Rosiane
déjà
alors sargissant chante c'est un jeune
c'est un jeune qui prendrait la vitesse
de l'éclair
et très bon mixeur
aussi carwana contre martiaux
un jeune prometteur qui dit hôtel assez
loin dans la Coupe du Monde
rapport bon rapport c'est c'est un genre
qui hongrois mais qui qui a changé de
fédération qui joue pour la Roumanie
maintenant depuis
depuis
quelques mois maintenant donc c'est le
numéro 1 roumain du coup et qui un jour
à ma tête 50 c'est un joueur un joueur
d'élite
contre ce coup girofle girofle c'est
aussi un joueur russe qui est qui a pas
loin de 2016 depuis depuis maintenant
[Musique]
pas loin de 10-15 années bon on les
connaît tous et
le joueur le plus jeune du tournoi c'est
c'est est-ce que c'est pas le joueur
indien de 17 ans le grand maître non
[Musique]
bon là je malheureusement je connais pas
l'âge de tous les participants mais toi
ici bengo non il se déco je pense que
c'est l'âge de gokash
c'est pareil
pranave prana V il est plus
ouais il est à peu près stage là ça m'a
bien aussi que je connais j'ai vu
j'avais vu contre lui j'avais fait une
contrepana en tournoi il y a très
longtemps il est encore plus jeune que
maintenant j'avais fait trois fois
l'imposition sans faire exprès
j'avais une position complètement
gagnante j'ai fait trois fois même
position
donc j'avais fait nul
murzin volodar
russe à 25 60 il a à peu près le même
âge peut-être un peu plus jeune que
pareil je sais pas quel âge ils ont pour
se dire exactement
darda est déjà plus jeune non darda il a
plus que 17 ans je pense hein
je pense
après je me trompe peut-être mais darda
c'est un genre belge
impressionnant
je sais pas quel âge
[Musique]
je viens de me rappeler aussi qu'on a
quand même aussi Niman qui participe à
à 35 là
on a Sarine aussi qui est là
et
[Musique]
alors plus jeune que lui il y en a
sûrement de gens qu'on ne connaît pas
qui tu as mais bon il y a beaucoup
beaucoup
les jeunes aiment bien ça donc
après il faut être jeune il faut être
fort parce que on le rappelle pour
participer pour participer à cet endroit
il faut quand même avoir il faut quand
même avoir 2550 minimum ou alors être
champion de son pays ou alors avoir une
invitation
exacte voilà donc du coup il y en a pas
beaucoup des invitations
à peu près que ces gens-là qui meurt qui
allemand allemand c'est une grande star
enfin c'est la star montante allemand
c'est clairement le le monstre qui meurt
qui vient de passer de 1700 hello en
partie lente
et voilà donc là les joueurs qui
commencent et carcennes qui joue P3 face
à face à notre ami de
oups Hansen alors très bien
donc moi je vois pas encore le coup j'ai
juste vu sur une caméra qui a joué non
plus et ça lui casseurs salut à tous ça
va arriver salut chasseur
Mazet a gagné déjà oui il a un sur un
comme Moussard et mvl
on va aller voir MBL il y a un bug ça
partit il y a marqué qu'il a fait nul
ce qui n'est pas vrai ça c'est pas sa
partie
et du coup MBL ça bug donc
pour
master
ne faites pas attention à ça on va
enlever pendant que ça pendant que le
bug on va dire
pendant qu'il y a on va enlever ce bug
on va aller partir sur la partie de 45
du coup allez je vais essayer de vous
mettre à la caméra approprié quand même
ça peut être cool
le temps que ça se remettait à jour sur
cheescom au moins voilà donc là du coup
vous avez car c'est toujours avec F3
donc ça c'est une ligne qui est sympa
que j'ai pas mal joué avec les noirs
avec fougères une fois je suis en
tournoi à Barcelone mais il y a de ça
peut-être 10 ans et du coup je joue
contre un joueur un tournoi un maître
international chilien qui jouait 2 à
chaque partie et du coup à l'époque je
parlais beaucoup avec mvl je lui ai
demandé si s'il avait un tueur me donner
contre betterave 2 il m'a dit c'est
simple tu joues des cinq fougères et il
m'a donné le plan et j'ai fait comme ça
et sauf qu'on adore ça il m'a joué sur
B3 D5 ma page B2 il m'a joué E3 et du
coup je pouvais pas je fouger 4
OK et du coup je suis un peu perdu
[Musique]
ok j'avais 2002 le machin il avait 2004
et
l'idée en fait de Fougères c'est de soit
provoquer F3 soit sur un coup comme
cavalier F3 et ben va te faire [ __ ] en
F3 et de jouer avec une structure un peu
cassée chez les Blancs contre la part de
fou qui a été donnée chez les Noirs donc
c'est intéressant moi je joue avec avec
fou H5 généralement possible ici mais
le 4 c'est un sacrifice de viande donc
là tu vas dire
en fait de déprendre un cadre qu'on peut
le dame de qui est assez Triki
ok parce qu'en gros prise prise je
menace de faire de manger là et du coup
bah j'ai des pièces qui va sortir etc
tout va bien et si les blancs falloir
mangent encore une fois en F3 bah j'ai
échec en B5
ouais ok donc moi je connais bien la
position avec le fond en
parce que moi ok moi normalement je joue
sur F3 moi je faut H5 du coup est-ce
qu'il y a une différence
c'est pas bon
pour celle-là parce que du coup si on
fait ça il va y avoir des 7
et je perds
mais bon j'ai quand même foulé 50 encore
qui
c'est tout ça c'est bizarre
[Musique]
mais là apparemment il y a F2 échec bref
c'est un peu compliqué
mais apparemment c'est très bien pour
les Noirs mais mais bon à voir ouvert un
peu ce qui se passe mais là
je comprends pas ce qui se passe par
rapport aux différences de de variantes
parce que moi je connaissais pas vos F5
et du coup le 4 a été joué donc c'est
[Musique]
c'est intéressant car personne qui
envoie un Gambie c'est pas vraiment un
Gambie parce que normalement le pull
récupère
un pseudo Gambie si vous voulez et fou
j'essaie ça a été joué par Hansen vous
voyez il respecte beaucoup cancer il a
peur de la population
et
donc là du coup il va sûrement manger là
et je vais essayer 3 et sortir des
pièces rapidement et puis ça joue donc
Hansen c'est quand même un joueur qui
peut être dangereux dans ces cadrances
partie rapide tout ça après karacène est
clairement au-dessus quand même il faut
le dire il est il est quand même
beaucoup plus fort et caresser n'a pas
joué
j'espère qu'ils auront pas parce que
bah écoute
tout ce qui s'est passé dernièrement
je me demande si Cartier il va la jouer
la partie
qui pourrait refuser de la jouer que
carrément complètement
par rapport à ce qui fait et tout je
pense qu'il est capable il a dit qu'il
ne voulait pas jouer contre contre ces
mecs là mais il est aspiré une balle
dans le pied dans le dans le dans le
tournoi du coup enfin je pense qu'il est
capable je pense qu'il est capable et
de de de
d'ailleurs je pense que si se joue je
pense que ça va pas jouer
ok je pense que voilà par contre Naka je
vois pour le battre
je pense que par rapport à tout ce qu'il
fait le show etc je pense qu'il ne
jouera pas
ok donc voilà bon en tout cas bon après
voilà on connaît pas les dessous et tout
ça c'est pas ce qui se passe etc on n'a
pas toutes les infos non plus non il y a
beaucoup de monde donc on en sait rien
on n'en sait rien c'est vraiment pas de
bol quoi avec tout le avec le nombre de
joueurs qu'il y a c'est vraiment pas de
bol 6 ce jour
de faire le tournoi en tête quand même
en haut on va un peu du coup ce que fait
ce que fait
l'image s'il arrive à suivre car en
scène et puis on verra en tout cas je
pense que
enfin moi j'ai pas envie de voir ça
parce que pour l'échec pour l'image même
pour le championnat c'est pas cool qui
se passe comme ça donc si on peut éviter
l'incidence qui n'aime pas plus mal donc
je suis pour éviter ce genre de choses
tu vois ouais je comprends normal autant
que les choses se passent bien voilà
est-ce que alors je regarde vite fait
mais pour la partie mvl est-ce que
Nantes
[Musique]
pardon pour la partie de Mazet de Eden
VL hein je dis pour pour les gens qui
nous rejoignent c'est c'est pas
c'est pas mis à jour encore
c'est des petits bugs on peut pas voir
les parties on est parti
sur eux malheureusement
donc on a ici on a on a Jules qui a calé
noir s'il nageddorf si elle a à peu près
enfin assez standard c'est normal tout
ça
donc le H6
je suis pas spécialiste de la ccdienne
[Musique]
très souvent les blancs veulent je
pourrai 5 ou F5 ou les deux des fois
et pendant que noir ils vont quand même
c'est ça qu'elle va les bêtises souvent
ou c'est 5 c'est assez compliqué donc en
tout cas c'est c'est les positions où
clairement Jules joue pour le gain je
pourrais essayer de créer des choses
Jules qui peut faire une surprise dans
la comme ça parce que c'est un genre qui
est très très bon envie de faire rapide
qui est d'ailleurs en 2022 a
complètement explosé en termes de
résultats et de même sans mélo qui qui a
pris un beau coup qui est monté
quasiment 2700 élo
donc Jules qui est qui est très très
très chaud et en plus elle est quand
même ce qui lui correspondent bien donc
on espère peut-être voir
vraiment un beau toit de sa part en tout
cas Jules moi j'aime beaucoup le voir un
jeu parce que je trouve qu'il est il a
un jeu hyper propre alors qu'à la base
il avait pas un autre épreuve il y a
quelques années mais là du coup
[Musique]
il a pas gagné également les
championnats de France cet été
il est il est champion de France en
titre effectivement il a gagné cette
finale contre Paquereau
et regarder c'était super intense je me
rappelle de ce moment là
alors on a un petit peu derrière on a
aussi la partie si vous voulez voir la
partie de l'image qui est qui a des
blancs qui jouent l'anglaise contre un
60 voilà un peu ce qui se passe
rien de spécial et du coup la partie mvl
qui a pris complet malheureusement je
suis désolé on peut pas vous la montrer
mais on va revenir sur 45 pour l'instant
on n'a pas mvl d'où ça ou à rester un
peu sur carbone un peu ce qui se passe
du coup il y a eu puis on prend un
premier 5 donc là c'est une position
assez marrante c'est passé plein de
choses
on dirait un mélange de karaoké de
scandinave et des blancs d'un mix de
plein tube bizarre donc c'est chelou
alors MV malheureusement n'a pas de
caméra là Paul je suis désolé
mvl il joue comme table 6 et on a que 5
caméras une caméra pour la salle les
quatre caméras sur les joueurs et là MVN
n'a pas de
camembert on a les quatre premières
caméras pour les quatre premiers
sur un Carcassonne une canne sur dépôt
et une cam sur sur le sur rapport
et une cam bien sûr sur la salle de jeux
mais la salle de jeux nous envoie quand
même sur 47 en fait c'est la canne de la
salle de jeux c'est une cam qui qui
bouge si vous voulez du coup des fois ça
peut être là vous voyez à côté de 45 il
y a une caméra
vous voyez le gars je crois que c'est
celle-là ok celle-ci qu'on voit parce
que j'ai vu la vue et bon bref après
c'est pas important mais c'est des
caméras qui sont
comment dire
en mouvement quoi tout le temps
entre
il y a des parkings qui ont été il y a
plein de trucs voilà je pense que depuis
cette histoire ça a été ah oui et puis
[Musique]
c'est un peu il y a quand même c'est
quand même plus compliqué en plus il y a
un délai par rapport aux parties donc
vous imaginez la cadence c'est 15
minutes il y a un de 15 minutes
peut-être sur les résultats ou quoi bon
voilà quoi d'ailleurs il y a
ce que je voulais dire oui on a vu aussi
genre des des Championnats du Monde par
équipe on a vu que que Hans il a fait un
bruit tournant alors c'est une cadence
moitié rapide moitié lente donc il est
quand même moins fort en
brexit en tout cas notre minimum
donc on va voir en tout cas ce qui va se
passer donc 45 qui réfléchit qui prend
son temps là il y a plusieurs
plusieurs
que j'aime bien
au revoir donc voir quel quel schéma tu
vas d'opter ici moi je verrai bien le
développement qui qui gagne en temps sur
la dame donc c'est ça paraît tout à fait
logique
le champion en titre c'est pas mvl le
champion en titre c'est
[Musique]
en rapide mvl les champions en titre de
Blitz et le Blitz qui se jouera le 29 et
sur la chaîne avec Kevin
on sera là pour pour supporter
les joueurs ont joué je vais essayer
d'actualiser un peu la page
il suffit juste d'activer
du coup ça a bougé
pareil
[Musique]
les joueurs jouaient des parties enfin
je découvre sur le marché qui et nous on
les voyait pas donc dame 2 ça peut
paraître un coup bizarre mais en fait
c'est normal il fera un regard vous
voyez que le roi c'est la priorité il
faut mettre le roi d'abri en premier
donc il y a eu des grands rock avait les
D4 petit problème quand même sur le pion
c'est deux qui va être donné mais il
s'en fout un peu parce qu'il se dit une
menace avec le pion C7 et la dame en
prise
donc rock Caval le 4 et du coup il
défend le pion c'est de grâce à
l'obstruction du cavalier d'amitié et là
on peut imaginer sûrement un coup de
cavalier petite cavalier 2 pour venir
enlever ce cavalier des 4 menacé
éventuellement un cavalier F4 c'est la
partie et ça a été joué
c'est la partie en cavalier 2
[Musique]
donc c'est vous avez ce problème là sur
sur les hikids de transmission de la
feed que ce soit sur cheesecom sur les
chaises surtout ce que vous voulez c'est
c'est chez eux au Kazakhstan que ça bug
et du coup nous on peut pas suivre cette
partie là mais en espérant que la partie
la partie d'après on puisse
reprendre un petit peu
c'est le c'est le même c'est le même
problème un peu partout apparemment sur
tous les sites
donc du coup on va pas c'est pas un
souci
et ça lui propulse bienvenue à tous
alors Kevin thérieux lui il fête Noël tu
auras là demain il sera là demain et
Kevin dordy ben j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il était malade mais ça je ne savais
pas je l'ai aujourd'hui
donc c'est pas de qui tu me parles en
tout cas un collier mais du coup voilà
les deux Kevin ne sont pas là
aujourd'hui Kevin au carré voilà les
freins sont bien les Français ouais ben
on a mvl qui a un demi sur un qui a fini
de la vraie partie que là on peut pas
suivre on a on a Jul qui qui a gagné la
première et que là qu'il est qui jouait
là
première et qui maintenant affronté
quand même une grosse pointure une
affronté
[Musique]
je sais plus son nom c'était Artémis
à 2700 Elo et
lui en but c'est rapide très très
costaud et aujourd'hui c'est donc on est
sur la deuxième ronde sur 5 sur
synchrones aujourd'hui du coup
il y aura 13 rondes en tout 13 secondes
sur 3 jours 5 4
donc aujourd'hui à 5 ans mon panier de
notre ami thé vert menthe chanter
un petit peu le le
[Musique]
canapé ouais mais c'est assez cool ceux
qui ne le connaissent pas je vous invite
à aller suivre sa chaîne bien chill très
sympa
[Musique]
merci
est-ce qu'on a besoin de te présenter
sauf maintenant pas évidemment mais
connu comme le loup blanc
malheureusement je ne peux pas me faire
de de saut à moi-même
et que les modérateurs ou pas attends
je stream aussi sur twitch avec ma
chaîne c'est stouf donc n'hésitez pas à
passer si vous voulez si vous voulez
d'échec
je sais que des échecs des fois du code
naïms avec des potes mais généralement
on fait que des échecs ouais c'est là où
je suis plus fort on va dire
et tu as une chaîne Youtube également
j'ai aussi une chaîne Youtube c'est
pareil c'est tout
donc donc voilà
et donc prof coach d'échec de
professionnelle donc du coup je fais que
du contenu échec pour ça je pourrais
faire autre chose en stream mais bon je
serai pas aussi fort le TT ouais je l'ai
la dernière fois que je l'ai fait
c'était je sais plus quand
mais c'est vrai que pendant un petit
moment je j'avais un peu lâché parce que
le mardi soir j'étais occupé avec des
cours collectifs que je proposais sur ma
chaîne exact et
mais je j'ai fait la dernière fois j'ai
fait l'Arena Kings et la tête used quand
je fais quand je peux je le fais mais
l'horaire ne l'horaire ne me plaît pas
trop c'est à 18h maintenant je crois
et chez moi c'est 17h parce que j'habite
au Canaries j'habite pas du tout en
France c'est le jeudi c'est ça
c'est le mardi ouais
le mardi ok
je sais même pas mon vélo ça change
chaque mois mon vélo donc donc du coup
ouais non mais en fait oui bah j'ai
quand même 5 normes de mètres
donc j'ai pas encore eu de 1400 hello
donc on espère un jour
passer quand même ce titre merci Fatou
pour pour ça j'ai Fatou ça devrait ça
devrait arriver dans l'année là quand
même à quoi que non il y a qu'un seul
tournoi du coup c'est le tournoi
d'avoine ça va être le seul tournoi de
prévu cette année
il y aura peut-être d'autres mais bon
pour l'instant j'ai rien encore ça a été
vraiment à deux doigts merci les gars
pour vos pour vos trucs ensuite tu m'as
bien menton SAF il y a trois quatre ans
c'est possible j'ai fait un très mauvais
tournoi d'ailleurs
[Musique]
et puis bon après comme disait comme le
disait Baki quand j'ai gagné deux fois
l'arrêt navet il a il a dit sur le
stream de Kevin qu'il fallait qu'il
remette de l'ordre dans l'arenave parce
que c'était pas normal que moi je gagne
deux fois d'affilée et du coup je lui ai
fait la même réflexion quand il a gagné
la reine en IRL qu'il fallait que je
ramène un peu d'ordre donc
ok donc on espère avoir un souffle dans
la prochaine du coup pour la prochaine
édition
c'est ce qu'on c'est ce qu'on veut
après il est chaos dessus il est quand
même au dessus mais bon ok très très
impressionnant comme je le sais
c'est quand même ancien top 10 mondial
quand même
27-49 je crois le max qu'il a eu c'est
pas rigolo quand même c'est pas rigolo
en vrai
c'est des parties c'est des gagne c'est
non non c'est
des années d'expérience aussi quoi
juste
en plus quand tu joues avec comme ça tu
tu sais qu'il va rigoler en fait donc du
coup c'est c'est dur quoi bah c'est
exactement la même chose quand des
amateurs comme comme moi par exemple
jouent un joueur titré comme comme toi
ou pas touche c'est exactement le la
même forme de stress j'ai l'impression
bah ouais quand un mec qui est plus fort
que toi et tu sais que le mec tu sais
que pour gagner il faut faire export et
en fait
et voilà après je pense que s'il y a une
cadence où je peux le battre enfin il y
a un monde où je peux ou je peux ou je
peux le battre sur internet
en Bullet peut-être en blitz ou Bullet
voilà
parce qu'en vrai chéquier
juste
on a fait quatre fois ensemble avec
Étienne
en vrai en IRL ok tournoi tournoi dans
le Var tu sais il habite dans le Var et
en fait du coup
on se joue plusieurs fois et j'ai tout
le temps perdu et il y a eu plusieurs
fois où j'étais pas loin de de faire nul
gagner jamais vraiment
mais plusieurs fois où j'aurais pu ne
pas la perdre en vrai mais bon en fait à
la fin l'expérience et qui ont des
pièces et puis pour arriver à une
pollution qui à peu près égale ça prend
beaucoup de temps à la pendule alors que
lui bah il est tranquille tu vois et au
final tu finis par faire une erreur
parce que tu as mal au temps enfin en
gros il te met la pression de ouf et
vraiment fort donc c'est parti du jeu
c'est comme ça
mais ah oui cinq fois cinq fois que oui
merci et une fois de plus que j'ai joué
dans la partie il est dans le jazz base
la partie est surprise j'ai raté ma tour
contre contre
une partie où on a joué le championnat
de France de but en 2010 je crois et
table 1 avant dernière ronde et j'ai les
noirs et je me suis fait toute la partie
éclater
et puis à la fin on a trois secondes
chacun 3 secondes avec un crémant de 12
secondes donc c'était juste pour moi
j'avais mon cœur qui battait à 300 tu
vois et son roi il est un peu en zone
mat mais il a tous ces ponts qui avance
là en fait je peux rien faire donc soit
je le mate soit je perds et je fais un
échec pensant que j'avais la nuit de par
répétition et du coup je fais échec il
va lui la 2 cases une case où il gagne
et une case où il est maths moi dans ma
tête j'ai pas vu le mat je pensais que
j'avais pas habitué à droite
et du coup il a fait la mauvaise il a
pris la mauvaise décision il passe sur
la case et moi j'ai pas vu le match j'ai
vu la tenue que je pensais avoir du coup
je fais de l'autre échec et sur moi
c'est chape alors que j'avais attendu
à l'analyse ben je voyais rien en fait
pour te dire la vérité bon bah son roi
s'échapper j'ai abandonné et après avoir
abandonné il me dit que j'ai raté ma
tondeuse et il m'explique je lui dis
mais non
trois quatre fois à l'aveugle genre tour
là est trop là et moi si tu veux je le
voyais pas tu vois et
du coup j'arrive tellement j'étais
fatigué par le fait de
d'avoir bon là là il y a un problème
mais tellement
fatigué par la partie que j'arrivais pas
à comprendre ce qui me disait tu vois ok
ouais et qu'à la fin je lui il a fini
par me mettre la pollution et montrer
sur le cellier tellement c'était
ridicule tellement mais tu vois tu vois
le niveau de fatigue c'était mon truc
mais franchement c'est dur surtout sur
un tournoi comme ça de de rester de
rester vraiment concentré jusqu'à la fin
c'est des vrais exercices donc c'était
des parties il y avait quoi il y avait
eu peut-être 12 ou 13 rondes de 3 + 2 et
en plus j'avais joué contre tout le
monde j'avais joué contre dort show
contre Mazet contre un contre Bacro
j'avais joué
chicken chef je vais jouer beaucoup de
grands maîtres j'avais fait un peu j'ai
fait un bon tournoi
[Musique]
les yeux fatigués le corps fatigue la
tête fatigue tout fatigué sur ce genre
de tournoi vers la fin donc c'est normal
de ouais mais après encore une fois tu
joues contre un joueur aussi fort et ben
tu as beaucoup enfin tu as l'impression
qu'il joue la pression qui te fait pas
jouer à ton réel niveau parce que si
contre toi par exemple avec le matin
debout j'aurais voulu c'est ça
mais c'est vrai parce que quand je joue
c'est un truc que tu me montres je le
vois oui
c'est juste trop facile mais là tu es en
partie tu le vois pas tu vois c'est
ça et puis c'est la pression bah encore
une fois il y a le temps qui rentre en
jeu il y a la pression au fait de jouer
contre un adversaire que tu sais
beaucoup plus fort donc forcément
c'est des choses à prendre en compte
tu imagines un peu affiche ouais non
c'est clair c'est clair c'est clair
c'est clair c'était le bon ça reste
super souvenir c'est bien ce tournoi qui
était organisé à Nice
et super ça c'était vraiment un super
événement et puis jouer Bacro bah c'est
juste trop cool quoi
donc là du coup bienvenue à ceux qui
nous rejoignent
j'espère que vous êtes tous passés des
belles fêtes de Noël donc là pendant
trois jours on va être aux commentaires
du
championnat du monde de partir rapide et
ensuite
du 29 août ce sera le Blitz le donc 47
qui est quand même le grand favori la
compétition qui a un sur un qui mène la
danse pour l'instant et puis on va un
petit peu
et donc on a toujours le même souci de
retransmission pour les parties des
français ici
et de Mazet on va pas ouais là je peux
malheureusement pas regarder les parties
de mvl ça bugge toujours basé pareil on
peut aller voir Jules rapidos ouais
carrément
et du coup Jules on va quand même vous
mettre les Noirs donc c'était une nage
d'or avec Laurent c'est complètement
normal et on voit un pion qui a été
mangé ça généralement le pur en cas de
témoins c'est bon signe pour les noirs
on va quand même voir ce qui s'est passé
donc dame 1 ok bon il veut laisser
passer le fou pour C8 tous les trois
d'imbé 6
cavalier bouge qu'avait G4 c'est normal
aussi on va venir sur ces cases là c'est
beaucoup ce que fait Jules on reprend
donc le roi E7 dans la nage d'offre les
gars c'est tout à fait normal n'ayez pas
peur F6
tours thématique alors ouais dans la
nage d'orf dans toutes ces semaines là
tout repense 3 c'est hyper pratique pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
le roi blanc devient faible et la
deuxième tube le plus regarde souvent
devient une cible dame C5 attaque les
deux pions B3 C3 roi des deux forces C8
et du coup on va réussir à manger depuis
113 donc il a pas encore mangé dans
cette forêt il a commencé par le
cavalier F2
voyez donc là il a réussi à manger quand
même deux pions et il a plein de casques
sont très bonnes donc le roi blanc qui
se balade alors que le renard est quand
même plutôt safe tranquille hashtag
emprise mais on s'en fout un peu d'âge 5
si vous voulez parce que il menace rien
et j'ai le temps de défendre mes pions
s'il le faut ou quoi mais là pour
l'instant ce qui est urgent c'est de
jouer contre le roi blanc en plus là il
y a une force royale qui est qui
traînerait
sur la prison en H5 c'est pas possible
du coup mais là on peut imaginer un
petit cavaler c'est 5 à base de
cavaliers prend fou
et une fois que le Fou est parti ben
faire la dame C2 et arrivé la dame
ranger en tout cas ouais belle position
pour les pour les pour les Noirs Jules
qui est en train de faire une
masterclass avec 7 minutes à la fois
contre 49 secondes
je vois bien Jules gagné cette partie
avec les noirs
ce serait ça serait juste génial
en tout cas ça m'a l'air bien parti pour
ce tout là pour l'instant
et Jules franchement un Jules en forme
peut faire un excellent tournoi donc
un champion du monde je sais pas mais en
tout cas un jus d'enfant peut peut vous
surprendre ça c'est clair
n'est pas là on ne sait pas on n'a pas
de raison on n'a pas eu d'infos à ce
sujet là donc
moi je pense c'est un coup qui est pas
mal parce que
était possible je pense parce que du
coup ton chien n'est pas possible à
cause de tampon à cause de la dame donc
du coup je peux peut-être que c'était
pas possible j'en sais rien et voilà le
roi qui vient redescendre le pion
tranquillement je presse pas j'aime bien
aussi le coup d'âme des cinq parce qu'au
final ça laisse quand même voyez la case
pour le cavalier ici qui va venir
attaquer soit la tour soit le fou mais
aussi proposer un jour éventuellement
une fourchette mais voilà la dame donc
pour l'instant il y a la tour et le fou
le fouet cloué mais après tout reprend
ben il faut que la dame mais oui même
matériellement en fait pour ceux qui
auraient peur de dire ouais mais j'ai
quand même perdu une qualité d'un
matériellement j'ai quand même deux
pions
j'ai quand même cavalier deux pions pour
pour la tour ce qui fait quand même
trois plus de 5 donc ça fait quand même
qualité
par contre en terme de position
donc le roi blanc est quand même plus en
difficulté que le roi noir et puis mais
énormément la pression au temps
également sur sur cette partie ah ouais
il y a plus de 10 secondes à la pendule
pour pour yvitch
qui avait été très surprenant l'année
dernière lors de la Coupe du monde
[Musique]
et il a été hyper hyper impressionnant
je sais pas ce qu'il avait fait
exactement comme résultat je peux pas
vous dire mais il avait été monstrueux
il avait gagné enfin il avait passé
plein de Tours
français 5 et on voit que Jules a gagné
donc je peux penser que du coup yvitch à
jouer son coup en perdant autant ah oui
je pense que c'est peut-être ce qui
s'est passé
en tout cas pense à ça qu'il y aura eu
une prise alors je sais pas de quelle
pièce
et après sûrement la prise aussi des
pions réussissent
avantage mais il a gagné autant ce qui
est plutôt cool
mvl on voit que la partie enfin ils ont
enlevé le score en tout cas
mais ils ont toujours la même partie sur
le même bug et Mazet c'est pareil donc
malheureusement on peut pas les voir je
suis vraiment désolé pour ces problèmes
là malheureusement c'est indépendant de
notre volonté tout ça on aurait bien
voulu suivre un verre
et salut tochou salut à tous du coup oui
Jules 202 très bien salut
j'imagine qu'on aura même si on voit pas
les parties on aura les résultats à la
fin de à la fin de la ronde concernant
si ça se met automatiquement non
pour les mettre
dans tous les cas dans tous les cas
voilà mais là j'ai pas j'ai pas du tout
accès à partir
ça dépend de moi non c'est pareil sur
tous les sites dans tous les cas c'est
retransmission
et on n'a pas les caméras non plus de du
coup de séjour là pour pour essayer de
deviner un petit peu ce qui se passe sur
les chéquiers après où est-ce que un
gros événement il y a quand même 90 90
échiquier retransmis en même temps ça
demande quand même une très très grosse
organisation
ok vous pouvez me dire qu'ils auraient
pu s'arranger autrement mais quand même
bon après c'est quand même un boulot
monstre en plus c'est pendant Noël enfin
c'est pas simple quand même comme manga
donc après gave l'événement qu'elle me
super cool donc c'est cool
voir ce qui se passe on espère quand
même que il y aura pas ce problème à
chaque fois on a qu'un VL parce que ça
ça
c'est quand même envie de voir de voir
ces
son talent à l'oeuvre
sur le chat bienvenue à tous joyeux
deuxième ronde donc on va
on voit quand même notre petit carcène
qui qui m'impression parce que les
pièces sont bien placés pas de problème
H4 qui peut être un jour une cible
attention à ce point H4
mais tu vois il y a une part de fou qui
est quand même assez actif on peut
imaginer un petit prix et il faut à ça
qu'il pourrait arriver ici et le renard
qui est quand même plus faible que le
roi blanc parce que les pièces les plus
actifs tout simplement mais sur X5 y a
pas roi prend B5
il joue vite ça ça il prend une pièce
donc je peux pas faire ça parce que
c'est très tactique déjà
Mazet perdant MVN nul
ouais mais en fait les parties sont sont
pas les bonnes à moins que ça soit calé
mais non mais c'est pas les c'est pas
les bonnes parties malheureusement
c'est pas la bonne partie du tout
regardez il y a des bugs en fait si tu
veux
c'est parti là sont pas les bonnes
parties
et vu la bienvenue ouais mais c'est pas
les bonnes
il y a que la partie du coup qui a été
qui a été retransmis correctement donc
avec le vrai score donc on aura le score
à la fin à la fin de la ronde imaginant
peut-être il faut actualiser je veux
actualiser encore une fois mais
malheureusement
[Musique]
ok
mvl c'est toujours la même et Mazet a
perdu
tu peux voir rapidement ce qui s'est
passé on peut voir la partie quand même
OK
tout ça c'est sûrement théorique
sur
le CASE noir il joue faut ça à la place
il faut A3 ok c'est étrange je trouve
mais il veut vouloir mettre ses pièces
sur les cadenas il paraît du coup le
pion des 4
et il vient quand même
qui est cette position elle me parle
vraiment pas mal j'ai vu une partie de
je sais plus ok un peu du même genre
j'arrive plus à me souvenir qui
mais là n'importe les noirs sont quand
même plutôt pas mal ici
j'ai peur un petit peu avec ce cavalier
là qui risque d'être perdu
qui menace du coup de tour des selles je
pense la dame est enfermée
et c'est pour ça qu'il a joué la tour
prend fou pour essayer de s'en sortir et
à mon don parce que pour la éteins la
table ok je pense en fait que je pense
en fait que il a fait il a il a mal jugé
la pollution donc bon moi je sais pas
j'ai pas j'ai pas l'ordi là
malheureusement l'ordinateur me ne vient
pas mais j'ai l'impression que ce petit
plan ici a des pions des 4 etc voilà un
petit peu un petit peu osé cavalle F6 là
pas possible bien sûr je pensais
peut-être que ça peut prendre alors leur
dit qui est venu et leur dit que
ok je connais pas du tout
du coup j'arrive pas à voir leur des
problèmes
je l'ai pas non plus de mon côté donc je
pense que c'est
j'arrive pas à l'avoir non plus de mon
côté ok en tout cas Mazet qui s'est pris
une bonne raclée ça va pas être facile
encore une fois la Dark sarde de Mazet
qui qui est hyper chaud en blitz
et du coup mvl la partie qui marche
toujours pas on va revenir sur 145 quand
même qui met une belle pression encore
une fois un tombé 6 va arriver avec une
petite en l'air encore une fois
et salut super looping salut à tous
bienvenue Bienvenue
[Musique]
c'est compliqué je pense qu'il y a aussi
un très très gros respect
bon il y a une qualité de plus c'est une
potion qui est perdue quoi juste on va
monter le roi tac tac on va faire des
choses et ok quand c'est une propre
jusque là 202 2 sur 2 ouais imperfect
pour l'instant est-ce qu'on a du coup
une partie intéressante à avoir
bon un rapport un rapport qui est un
joueur très très créatif avec les Blancs
qui aiment beaucoup les positions très
chaudes et les Gambie
et un jour que tu aimerais bien je pense
un joueur qui est vraiment très agréable
à regarder
alors du coup
alors comment comment prononce son nom
donc un joueur russe alors ouais donc là
il va perdre là mais si il mange là il
va essayer du coup de
manger un des pions comment il veut
faire
peut-être sur ça il veut que cavalier
[Musique]
qui mange le pion directement comme ça
tac tac
ok ok
blanc qui va jouer avec torfu contre
tour parce que le pion c'est deux tombe
croix bouge va y avoir tort là dans là
et ça va jouer ça va jouer
il y a peu de temps attendu là qui aime
cinq minutes pour les noirs pour 30
secondes donc la règle c'est qu'ils ont
50 coups pour la gagner
pour la gagner et sinon ça fait nul du
coup
je vais vous mettre la caméra qui
correspond
pour rapport est-ce que girofle
et
du coup
ça c'est une position qui est nul
théorique mais en pratique qui est un
enfer à défendre pour pour le noir à ce
niveau là normalement
ça va tenir oui
mais moi je vous dis j'aimerais pas la
tenir avec les noirs
bon j'ai réussi à tenir deux fois dans
ma vie mais
en fait c'est hyper dur parce que en
pratique c'est en vrai je pense qu'un
joueur à peu près de 2400 2500 hello je
pense qu'une fois sur deux ça fait en
vrai ok peut-être un peu moins quand
même 1 sur 3 ça perd peut-être
et plus le plus le hello monte plus
c'est nul mais tout à l'heure il y avait
un jour à 22 tu te souviens oui lui je
pense que
il a beaucoup la perdre
ce que c'est très dur en pratique même
si tu connais la priori et tout c'est
très très qui
moi j'avais tenu cette position au Cap
d'Agde contre un grand maître français
et je vais arrêter des maths et du coup
son roi s'échapper et puis finalement il
aime manger tous les pions un par un et
j'ai dû tenir cette finale alors que
j'avais quatre pions pour le fou quoi à
la base c'était moi qui attaqué quoi
mais bon j'ai foiré et au final ben on a
eu ça et j'avais quand même fini là
donc
mais normalement oui ça va ça va jouer
c'est clair que ça va jouer
et merci
Drena et oui en effet ouais c'est c'est
juste la pratique des puzzles en effet
Miller plus de 1000 heures de puzzle
et des nuits blanches
mais ok et pour concernant la partie du
coup mvl on a toujours pas on a toujours
pas plus d'infos malheureusement
je vais regarder
ah c'est bon
on va revenir après sur cette sur cette
partie de rapport parce que j'ai envie
de voir cette technique voir ce qui se
passe carrément et on va prendre depuis
le début si vous voulez très très vite
parce que il y a beaucoup de temps la
pendule c'était une ah la fameuse ok une
sorte de espagnol avec carré.2 smooth
parti ou la Camorra a battu
karwana
aux candidat
c'est très bizarre tout ça mais il y a
quand même deux pièces pour la tour pour
pour les blancs avec des pions pour les
noirs et l'activité donc tu vois au
niveau du matériel c'est ça c'est assez
compliqué
au final les blancs vont au fur et à
mesure manger les pièces
ici faut trois tours là cavaler tout en
prise
tu manges là je mange là
[Musique]
c'est la tour arrivée
les Noirs poussent les pions c'est pas
simple
il mange quand même le pion a ok ça
c'est déjà une bonne chose de fait en
réalité j'aime bien ce cavalier Angers 5
qui permet aussi de prendre les caisses
du roi au cas où et de mettre un jour le
roi aux autres mats et là ça va faire
annuler ça fait nul parce que ok
parce qu'en fait c'est tu attends avec
les Noirs je vais faire trois là et là
je suis matte avec ton reprenais sexe
[Musique]
apparemment il y a eu un gain de raté
peut-être
ou pas
non je crois pas
mais
c'est un très très bon joueur
une grosse partie grosse partie en tout
cas des joueurs tabataba qui a annulé
Naka puis mvl en deux parties quand même
c'est super important
[Musique]
très très sympathique vous connaissez
bien très sympa
quand il me paraît il m'appelle body
chaque fois
je suis pas un body moi vous voyez la la
la Fnac qui joue encore et
en vrai je suis pas sûr de
je suis pas sûr
déjà il était à 10 secondes tout à
l'heure il est remonté à une minute donc
ça joue quand même les coups assez
rapidement
après ça tourne ça tourne ça tombe il a
50 coups pour la gagner
et après 50 coups mais je suis pas sûr
qu'il va vraiment les réclamer parce
qu'en fait l'idée c'est que la règle
c'est 50 coups sans prise ni mouvement
de pions donc là il y a plus de prise
possible ni mouvement de ton possible et
des échecs aussi ou pas forcément
OK et du coup le problème c'est que eux
vu qu'il n'aime pas des coups et qui
savent pas ce qui se passe et ben ils
ont pas moyen de savoir comment
je crois que la règle c'est 50 coups
sans prise ni mouvement de pions et si
on a un qui réclame la nul qui appelle
Larabie qui a quand même
etc et que ça fait 50 coups ben
s'accordait je crois que ça avait pas 50
coups je crois qu'il a des pénalités de
temps un truc comme ça par contre si au
bout de 70 coups et ben les joueurs ne
réclament pas et bah l'arbitre va
eux-mêmes leur dire bon les gars ça fait
70 coups ça fait une gueule
ok donc là on peut voir la dernière
pièce de prise c'était 51e coup
du coup ben ça me saigne beaucoup quoi
donc 101 101 les joueurs peuvent
acclamer s'il le fait avant je crois que
c'est pénalité s'il le fait pas et ben
c'est perdu est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
aille voir un petit peu dépôt la radio
contre aravine
de c'est un
un super joueur aussi du circuit bon
bien sûr n'est pas on le connaît on va
pas présenté c'est le joueur qui est qui
a joué contre
contre quinzaine du coup
un championnat du monde et qui va jouer
maintenant qu'on regarde scène du coup
enfin pendant contre Ding Batman et
ravint c'est un jeune Indien une jeune
une jeune promesse
qui hop j'ai mis la Meuse caméra désolé
non c'est bon
nepoiding d'ailleurs
nepozings
je suis pas sûr est-ce que dans le chat
vous avez
la réponse j'ai
à 75 Quentin ok je crois que 70 merci à
toi pour pour
[Musique]
ton ta précision
75 coups c'est l'arbitre qui avril ouais
je crois que c'était par là
je pense qu'il y a une date et pas de
date encore
donc voilà donc du coup là on voit ne
pourra ravint c'est un jeune Indien qui
était très très fort quand il était
jeune pour il est toujours très fort il
a 2600 hello 17 ans il a une pièce de
plus vous voyez à ravint il a une pièce
de plus il faut qu'on est pot
sauf que là j'ai l'impression que la
caméra et ben
j'ai l'impression que il y a moins de
pièces
que ça a bougé attendez je vais
actualiser la page
sur ton partage d'écran et la caméra est
partie ou à la gare ça y est
la caméra qui est parti pourtant sont
sur mon BS la caméra est là donc je sais
pas ce qui se passe
mais
du coup
[Musique]
on a on a encore une fois un bug de
retransmission ce qu'on ne va pas on ne
va pas les les joueurs malheureusement
enfin on n'arrive pas à voir la partie
je vais voir si les meilleures caméras
que ça pour vous montrer la partie
malheureusement ouais j'ai peut-être une
meilleure caméra mais vous allez
peut-être pas bien la voir
allez on part là-dessus
est-ce que vous voyez mieux la partie
peut-être parce que j'arrive pas bien à
voir ce qui se passe
non je pense qu'on est pareil
je crois qu'on est pareil
on peut pas zoomer malheureusement
mais normalement une pièce de plus ça
devrait gagner quand même pour pour
le peine de Cannes OK et il avait 14 ans
voilà il avait 14 ans il était tout
petit
non OK
comme ça
il avait
en 2009 non
il a pas non c'était après
cette en
[Musique]
2013 peut-être 2013 peut-être
et il avait 14 ans comme ça
et du coup
je sais que quand je joue un petit jeune
j'ai tendance à
être plus impressionné et plus effrayé
que quand je joue une personne un peu
plus âgée par exemple bah soit toujours
un mec vraiment vraiment tu as par
exemple si tu joues un mec comme je sais
pas un mec qui a l'expérience tu as
jamais un gris de Souk par exemple c'est
impressionnant après tu vas un goût
cache impressionnant aussi mais d'une
autre manière tu vois c'est ça après de
manière générale tu préfères au même élo
tu préfères jouer un adulte ben oui je
vais mettre allemand parce que le jeune
m'avait progressé il est un peu
imprévisible bon la partie on voit rien
les gars je pense qu'on va aller sur
notre partie
est-ce qu'il y a une partie intéressante
je vois que les parties ont quasiment
toutes finis
en tout cas pour pour Maxime ça fait ça
fait deux nuls à cette deuxième ronde
ouais mais ok là j'ai deux grosses
parties
c'est pas du tout enfin c'est deux nuls
qui sont on va dire à peu près enfin qui
sont ok hein
pas contre des plots donc clairement
clairement c'est pour moi c'est pas du
tout
pas du tout
surprenant quoi ça prenne normal on va
dire et puis là cette partie de rapport
judo il y a toujours ce yoyo pour pour
aller jusqu'au
est à 12h30
du délai il y a souvent du retard en
fait toute la cadence elle est un
incrément et tout ben on n'est jamais
sûr donc il est parti peu durer plus
longtemps que prévu quoi du coup là on a
vu par exemple la ronde un il y a des
parties qui qui ont duré plus d'une
heure plus d'une heure et demie
en tout cas voilà bon bon début en tout
cas pour pour mvl en ce qui concerne
Mazet 1 et demi enfin un demi un demi
ouais et là on a Moussard qui a Jul qui
a 2 sur 2 qui a écrasé d'adversaires
forcément Jules qui Jules qui est qui
est en forme maintenant ce dans ce début
tournoi on espère que ça
que ça continue donc on voit Richard
Harper quand même qui qui tient bien la
partie parce que c'est pas simple de
tenir cette finale et
donc il y a pas mal de de techniques
différentes pour tenir la nul neiman et
la 202 ok
l'image du coup qu'il avait gagné cette
partie là mais j'ai pas vu qu'il a pris
finalement je sais pas ce qu'il avait
fait apparemment il a le 2 sur 2 ok
si je dis pas de bêtises
Guiri qui remporte sa partie contre
[Musique]
c'était pas c'était pas un
super appareil pour une ronde un vous
voyez c'était quand même chaud et comme
à l'aise qui a aussi du coup un sur deux
avec deux nuls mvl puis Naka donc le
tournoi qui est monstrueux on a aussi
irrigazie alors erégasi c'est un joueur
qui qui en 2022 a fait une année de
folie plus de 100 points à vélo et un
blé de c'est rapide il a quasiment de
2800 et l'eau dans les deux cadences
ergazide qui a 18 ans ou 19 peut-être
19 je crois et
qui a 2731
donc une grosse star et lui par contre
en but c'est rapide franchement je pense
qu'il est capable de faire des très très
bonnes choses en tendance
ok il faut le suivre
au Patriote indien là
s'abonner qui est aussi très très chaud
qui est aussi qui était membre de de
l'équipe olympique de l'Inde quand elle
a fait vice championne olympique
[Musique]
qui est là aussi
monstrueux très très fort comme toi
tu as encore des grands mètres quoi
quelques amis quelques quelques maîtres
filles mais on a un candidat maître si
je dis pas de bêtises
il y a des joueurs qui sont qui sont qui
sont enfin ça fait nul ça fait nul la
partie il y a des gens qui sont pas
littrées mais après bon ils sont invités
ou quoi après je pense que s'ils sont là
c'est quand même qu'il y ait des
méritent pas c'est qu'il y a des bonnes
raisons j'imagine
alors je vais vous mettre si vous voulez
la caméra de la salle le jeu parce que
il y a plus de parties enfin les
premières tables ont terminé si vous
voulez
pas le résultat de sa partie par exemple
mais pas je vois qu'il a plus de temps
[Musique]
je vous ai mis qui comme caméra là
c'est bonne soirée
du coup
où es-tu van forest
dans la partie
que je ne connais pas en tout cas
[Musique]
elle est blanc ça c'est une finale
malheureusement
[Musique]
pour une forest malgré le malgré le pion
de plus c'est
l'option qui n'avancera pas ça c'est
connu pour un petit côté
et là on fait échec en fait on va juste
attendre
les blancs
dans ton dernier cours de groupe un
mercredi je m'en rappelle ouais c'est
final comme ça
et celle-là elle est là c'est simple à
tenir à ce niveau là en plus bon c'est
un Fantin et donc normalement ici il y a
pas grand chose à dire en fait
et ça nous est tous arrivé de tomber sur
ce genre de position en partie en ligne
sur internet je pense tous les joueurs
qui jouent toujours régulièrement ce
genre de
ce genre de finale ça arrive assez
régulièrement alors pourquoi draw je
sais pas si tu parles cette partie là
ZPN Nice donc si tu parles d'avant avec
tofu parce qu'en fait il y avait plus de
50 pouces en prises mouvements de pions
dans celle-là en fait les blancs peuvent
pas progresser parce qu'il faut qu'il
défende le pion
et voilà
qu'est-ce qu'il a foutu van forest qui
va gagner
à Tours et voilà regardez la caméra
le joueur qui a complètement t-il je
sais pas si vous avez vu hein
vous allez vendre forest qui s'est
redressé et qui ajoute tempo et
l'adversaire qui se qui secouait la tête
complètement tilté son
erreur ici bah il a il a poussé un peu
sur le Barça à la faute
et puis tu auras un donc forcément
une case ou il ne pourra pas du coup
défendre le pion et sur voilà et là
c'est un prochain et quand on rapproche
je fais chèque et dames et un pas
le choix c'est la seule chance de
pouvoir
tenir enfin essayer de faire nul cette
finale là les gagnantes pour les blancs
mais elle connaît mais elle est elle est
pas si simple que ça en pratique mais
bon vent forest il va la gagner facile
pour lui c'est facile son adversaire qui
doit quand même être dépité ah oui moi
ça comme quoi
ça gros erreur ça a été de faire tourner
parce que là du coup je vais mettre la
tour qu'est-ce que je voulais
[Musique]
c'est quoi pardon OK
il faut attendre comme ça
malheureusement et là à temps là et
c'est fini
c'est fini parce que maintenant du coup
le roi arrive à passer
normalement
sur wash 7 on verra mais je vais voir
échec échec on va progresser petit et ça
va on le voit bien sur la tête de son
adversaire que
que c'est compliqué
après ça la rendent deux
c'est la rampe 2 c'est pas encore fini
et c'est vrai que c'est vrai que ça fait
un peu tilter tu dis que tu allais faire
nul avec les Noirs contre one forest
c'est un cadeau c'est un super super
joueur
tu te fais planter oui mais les jours en
fait la pression que ça soit autant sur
l'échiquier plein de Trappes possibles
et au final tu fais souvent partir à
partir un petit peu
arnaquer quoi si tu veux
c'est c'est même même à ce niveau là et
puis bon je pense que chacun doit aussi
pouvoir gérer sa pression un peu
différemment mais mais comme tu l'as dit
avec la pression du temps le fait de
jouer des joueurs le fait que ce soit
aussi pareil la deuxième ronde contient
une partie le fait de pouvoir la tenir
aussi sur le long terme là pour la
terminer la concrétiser enfin tellement
de choses en fait c'est un réel exercice
c'est donc
et du coup ça montre que que même au
niveau ben ça peut ça peut ça peut
craquer quoi
[Musique]
et c'est terminé
on va le voir sur la caméra bientôt ils
vont il va abandonner et voilà abandon
et voilà ce qu'il a acheté belle qui
gagne sa partie vraiment inextremis
donc je sais pas ce que la caméra va
nous amener les joueurs qui parlent je
pensais Guiri qui parle avant de Forest
donc guéri qui est qui est les Pays-Bas
comme vent Forest et donc guéri qui a
remporté sa deuxième ronde
il faut les battre trois fois oui en
fait je sais plus qui c'est qui disait
ça il y avait un
champion du monde qui disait que pour me
battre son battre trois fois dans
l'ouverture dans le milieu de jeu et en
finale et c'est ça et à ce niveau là en
fait éventuellement de ressources de
partout que les mecs tu les tu les bam
mais en fait non il y a toujours des des
faut pas l'acheter quoi c'est ça
la moindreureur peut peut être fatale et
là on l'a vu en fait notamment dans
cette partie c'était parfaitement
parfaitement illustré justement en plus
c'est typique parce que tu vois tu es le
joueur qui entre guillemets forts tu as
un pion contre une torption contre tour
donc c'est nul mais
c'est toi qui met la pression en fait du
coup tu vas essayer tu vas essayer
toutes les arnaques possible
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps et au final ben le
mec en plus c'est mal au temps donc il
va paraître menace paraît la deuxième
par la troisième puis voilà il peut s'en
prendre une parce qu'au final ben écoute
c'est
[Musique]
chaud quoi au bout d'un moment tu finis
par craquer mentalement craquer de
partout et c'est dur de garder une
position enfin de tenir la position
nulle quand c'est nulle plus fort c'est
quand on est gagnant des fois de pouvoir
gagner les parties je pense que dans le
chat tout le monde a déjà perdu des
parties
gagnantes ça c'est l'histoire de votre
vie un peu a toujours des chèques mais
c'est comme ça et en fait bah c'est
l'expérience qui va vous montrer un peu
comment faut faire mais c'est pas
évident là on avait plein de parties
gagnantes qui ont été perdus là la
partie là vous pouvez vous avez devant
les yeux c'est parti complètement nul et
au final ben il sait faire arnaquer
alors que le mec en face il est quand
même grand maître quoi il a 25 34
et même un grand maître vous voyez et
Ben et ben il perd une partie qui était
nulle assez élémentaire ça c'est des
parties qu'on va c'est les c'est les
finales de nul qu'on montre aux enfants
vous voyez et comme quoi
c'est cool même d'avoir été témoin de ça
parce que Ben à la fois c'est c'est à la
fois rassurant et ça montre que Ben même
les enfin on est tous des humains quoi
non non et puis et puis en tout cas moi
je sais qu'en tant que fin quand je joue
je sais que c'est un de mes un de mes
problèmes vraiment récurrents c'est de
de réussir à maintenir une position
gagnante et même de la concrétiser en
fait c'est c'est pas le tout d'avoir une
position gagnante mais il faut la il
faut pouvoir la conserver pouvoir la la
concrétiser et c'est c'est des exercices
qui sont vraiment pas simples et
concrétiser sans détériorer sa position
en fait c'est
c'est une partie c'est vraiment jusqu'à
la fin et du coup du coup c'est
jamais évident tous les jours quoi c'est
ça
[Rires]
en train de se jouer là pour ça je suis
sur en même temps c'est officiel
et là je vois que toutes les parties
sont terminées ok il y a pas encore la
rentrée mais ça va sortir d'ici peu donc
si vous voulez on fait une petite page
de pub peut-être trois quatre minutes et
puis on revient on revient pour cette 33
de quelques instants allez donc rester
reste sur le chat là restez là en ligne
on revient dans 3-4 minutes on va un
petit peu manger un petit truc et on
revient tout de suite yes tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on est de retour avec du bonjour
rapide donc si vous voulez j'ai les
apparisants est-ce que ça vous intéresse
je pense que oui cette troisième ronde
c'est ça donc pour l'instant je suis les
Français on a Jules Moussard qui mène
l'avance chez les Français puis aussi
donc je peux pas du monde avec deux sur
deux
on a Maxime va chez la grâce donc tu me
connais un mvl qui a un sur deux qui
fait deux matchs nul voilà et on a aussi
Sébastien Mazet qui a un demi sur deux
d'ailleurs moi je vois ici non pardon un
sur deux il a fait nul enfin il a gagné
la deuxième donc
voilà pour 3 français on peut se faire
un petit coucou à la Belgique un pays
francophone avec Daniel Dardar qui est
le numéro 1
numéro 1 belge qui a 2600 et l'eau et là
il a 0 sur 2 malheureusement dans ce
premier début de rapide
et mais bon il va remonter sur Monter
c'est un très très fort joueur il a il
est jeune il est la génération goût cash
il a 17 ans et de la 2006 c'est déjà pas
mal vraiment tout jeune voilà et donc là
du coup on va attaquer la troisième
ronde sur les cinq qui vont se jouer
aujourd'hui c'est ça donc apparemment je
vais vous donner si vous voulez on a 4
scène avec les Noirs contre Thomas
shevsky table 1 donc Thomas javski c'est
un client aussi il a eu 2700 hello toute
sa vie
on a table 2 Douda contre bluebom donc
bluebom joueur allemand 2600 et quelques
on a yu-yang contre shimanov
Moussa table 4 avec les Blancs contre
fedos et ça c'est un gros match on va
essayer de le suivre aussi en priorité
avec Maxime on a Artémis contre Kemer
dontchenko Guiri sindarov van forest que
des que des parties très chaudes on a on
a le Champion du monde en titre donc
Nord liberté
le 8 avec les Blancs contre Anton
demchenko
on a mis une Bassem donc amine Bassem
qui est qui est je ne sais pas combien
de fois champion d'Afrique qui a 202 et
qui joue contre Sam Champlan on a
ensuite on a le Turc Samal va 2 sur 2
contre ergy le joueur que je vous avais
dit qu'il fallait vraiment faire
attention qui est un joueur qui est qui
est vraiment capable de tout et ensuite
on a à 202 on a Sarine qui joue contre
Q paradis giga donc c'est deux joueurs
enfin c'est on va dire les 22 joueurs
ici qui ont deux sur deux après un an et
demi masse de joueurs donc il y a un
rapport népo carvana mamedia Rome DOF
matelas Coffe vite chez Paris 9 avec
Krishna bref
tout le monde beaucoup beaucoup de monde
à un et demi et puis aussi on a la
caméra on a MVM magritchouk
vous voyez en fait
et c'est assez monstrueux le niveau du
tournoi avec mvl avec un sur deux ils
font grand grand maître il tape 32
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu ml un open
top 32 je pense que les gars dans votre
vie vous avez jamais vu ça
ça monte bien quand même le niveau
le niveau de l'autoroute
elle est noire contre un grand maître
kazak
Denis donc bon 25 13 donc on espère que
Maxime va va mettre le point dans cette
troisième ronde pour
commencer un petit peu à revenir sur les
pas de caresses et ben on espère en tout
cas que il y aura pas de souci cette
fois-ci pour cette ronde là pour la
retransmission de la partie ouais ben on
espère qu'il y aura pas de problème on
voit que on voit que les filles ont
commencé donc je me demande si les mecs
ont commencé aussi malheureusement j'ai
pas les parties qui sont venus de
Sanchez comme de voir non j'actualise et
je vais rien sur le CSCOM j'ai pas les
parties j'ai rien sur cheesecom non plus
en tout cas en attendant la bienvenue à
zen bienvenue à toutes celles et ceux
qui nous rejoignent en cours de route
pour cette troisième ronde on a pas les
parties alors qu'on voit que les séjours
de tournoi commencé
peut-être que ça va pas tarder à arriver
j'espère que ça va on va cartonner qui
se dépêche qui court et qui a un
adversaire par contre c'est très bizarre
j'ai pas les parties sur piècecom j'ai
pas liberté non plus
pour vous dire je réactualise toutes les
toutes les toutes les deux secondes j'ai
pas les appareils
ronde 3 j'ai rien non j'ai rien non plus
alors que
Carlson va au premier coup que les noirs
on n'a pas les résultats les gars
comment on fait
si j'ai pas les parties
alors le deuxième site sur lequel tu
regardais c'était en fait c'est le site
officiel si tu veux c'est les résultats
mais j'ai pas les parties en elle-même
les parties ça le problème alors non je
peux je peux rien y faire là
j'ai pas les parties sur le télescope
comment on fait quand j'ai pas les
parties je peux vous mettre les caméras
malheureusement
au moins en attendant
[Musique]
mais vous allez pas avoir
enfin vous allez voir la caméra en grand
sur 47
j'ai pas mieux pour l'instant
c'est la retransmission sur tous les
sites c'est pareil et non on ne sait pas
pourquoi les raisins ne jouent pas ce
tournoi
on
n'a pas eu de raison il a pas envie il a
pas envie juste
ouais donc toutes les caméras
fonctionnent toutes les nickel par
contre voilà j'ai
pas les parties non j'ai pas les
appareils
donc malheureusement je peux pas vous
montrer alors je continue à utiliser
tout le temps
et
c'est comme ne me propose pas alors je
vais essayer de passer par autre chose
est-ce que c'est vous comme ça que chez
moi ou est-ce que sur d'autres mais je
vois que même JETCOM apparemment sur
d'autres sites c'est pareil ils mettent
tous les ventes
est-ce que sur par exemple mettre les
caméras en grand aussi
je prends la pub
toujours pas toujours pas toujours pas
les appareils
je pense que c'est des problèmes pour
tout le monde
il y a un problème oui en fait des fois
il y a plein plein de problèmes
techniques ça peut arriver tout ça donc
du coup ben c'est un autre gérer on voit
tous les sites
de tweet cheeseccom
Escom bon bah États-Unis quoi et ils ont
tous la même truc que nous donc on va
rester comme ça pour l'instant en tout
cas c'est bon bah on voit la caméra
malheureusement on peut pas faire
grand-chose de plus j'ai que ça je suis
désolé mais on verra en tout cas en
favoris c'est 45 bien évidemment
il a il a été trois fois champion du
monde à partir à rapide et en blitz j'ai
pas regardé mais je pense qu'il a été
trois quatre fois aussi quatre fois
aussi
[Musique]
le genre le plus complet de circuit et
le plus fort et là il a deux sortes
dedans pour l'instant ça montre que
quand même il a sa forme il a envie de
gagner
et voilà quoi donc
peut-être pas mais après c'est sur des
événements de grande ampleur qui demande
beaucoup de qui demande énormément de
techniques donc forcément c'est c'est
pas évident d'avoir tout qui fonctionne
quand on s'éclate la technologie n'est
pas forcément infaillible alors du coup
la version de carton c'est Thomas
shevski Thomas chelski un joueur russe
qui a eu 2700 hello toute sa vie
2720 à peu près tout le temps
actuellement je sais pas combien il a
mais
voilà en tout cas bon très très bon
joueur qui a deux sur deux quand même
donc c'est pas un client car c'est le
noir va essayer de pousser à la faute
mais à ton machiavski en forme c'est
aussi un très bon joueur donc c'est
compliqué alors voilà position et c'est
une sorte de de l'hippopotame
et les deux cavaliers au milieu comme ça
s'appelle hippopotame c'est une
ouverture qui va jouer à ce niveau
normalement
donc c'est réputé pour être pour être
archi solide et même même un peu trop
d'ailleurs ouais c'est réputé pour être
bizarre en fait bon après c'est aussi
une ouverture un peu test
parce que du coup les blancs ils ont ils
prennent le centre ils passent bien leur
pièce ils font tellement tout bien qu'à
un moment donné
c'est pas si simple tu vois et et du
coup oh non moi je vois ça un peu comme
une ouverture test
[Musique]
pas forcément tu vois que je joue Thomas
théorie pas contre un mec comme ça voilà
après dans ce genre de dans ce genre
d'ouverture il y a bien un moment donné
où il faut où il faut il faut envoyer
prendre une décision ben à un moment
donné à un moment donné il va balancer
C5 ou F5
plutôt c'est 5
ça dépend des pauses mais tu vois
regarde avec les Blancs il met cavaliers
au centre il met des fous au centre il
met les tours au centre
il a tout fait bien quoi qui est blanc
c'est ça ouais c'est ça c'est et puis
après voilà
[Musique]
nous ça joue face à dépôt dans Moussa
résoudre contre
je sais plus enfin je vais vous dire là
15 + 10 ouais
malheureusement je peux pas vous montrer
les parties parce que j'ai pas les
parties sur tiascom ça n'apparaît pas ça
bug et je vois que sur tous les autres
twitch c'est pareil c'est un grand écran
on a un problème de caméra et donc du
coup je peux pas aller voir mvl parce
que pas sa partie et même les caméras je
suis pas sûr d'avoir une caméra sur vous
voyez derrière on voit d'obs et juste
derrière toi on voit la la touffe de
c'est la touffe de Jules
on voit c'est on voit cette petite
couette enfin c'est pas c'est quoi qui
envoie c'est
voilà c'est Jules qui est derrière
malheureusement on voit pas la partie
mais du coup je peux pas voir ça partie
malheureusement vous allez voir le
reflet de mes lunettes de
non je peux rien faire tranquille Thomas
qui joue solide et voir un peu parce que
certaines joue
bah n'empêche tu vois ça je trouve ça
marrant de voir ça justement à ce niveau
là j'ai hâte de voir comment comment va
se dégoter cette pire c'est qui va
gagner quoi
comme tu dis son adversaire c'est quand
même pas un client donc
en fait c'est tellement un truc bizarre
tu vois et puis on garde ça il joue en
fait personne il est tellement plus fort
quand même ça montre bien que à ce
niveau là il peut toujours être quoi
c'est ouf mais de toute façon ça s'est
vu sur la tête de son adversaire quand
il a commencé à faire son setup ça s'est
vu il a regardé un peu
qu'est-ce que tu es en train de me faire
là tu vois c'est clair c'est aussi
intéressant d'avoir le d'avoir le
d'avoir les images des joueurs parce que
parce que il y a il y a le langage le
langage du corps le non verbal qui parle
aussi
je peux le mettre la caméra si vous
voulez mais le problème c'est que vous
allez rien voir
c'est une caméra où on voit pas les
jeter après si vous voulez voir un jeu
on peut aller voir un jeu
je vous mette Jules
juste pour le voir trois secondes après
on va partir sur 45 parce que au moins
là on a une position enfin on a une
caméra si vous voulez qui nous permet de
voir la position alors que c'est que je
vous mets à l'instant celle de Jules
vous allez pas réussir à avoir la
position
mais après après
d'ailleurs la partie que vous voyez elle
a aucun sens parce que dans la partie
juste
[Musique]
c'est pas du tout eux mais vous voyez là
on a là on voit on voit Jules quand on
fait nos CF Jules qui bien habillé en
classe
c'est pas c'est pas la partie en
question
et moi je supporte pas cette vue
on va revenir sur une meilleure caméra
du coup voilà son meilleur scène je
voulais mettre la caméra en grand pour
que vous puissiez pour que vous puissiez
tout ça après chestello non je pense que
là c'est un peu abusé je pense que tu
vois il y a quand même 90 échecs qui
retransmis tout ça il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à faire niveau à
regarder écoute c'est pas
ok du coup donc c'est une Française
française de fédoc contre Jules
et
du coup
cavailleuse 7 là le but des blancs c'est
être un cavalier si on fait en E5 contre
5 donc souvent tu m'incavel en Détroit
et tu mets faux F4 et tu mets une pièce
du coup sur
sur la carte de 5 tu vois
et
[Musique]
donc voilà après les Noirs ils vont
plutôt jouer sur la colère tout ça
intéressant
et je vais aller voir vite fait aussi
mvl tu dis qui joue table bois il joue
pas trop loin normalement mais là on le
voit on peut aller voir un petit peu MBS
si vous voulez vraiment il y a pas de
caméra sur lui parce qu'il joue il joue
au fond de la salle
et donc ok il joue un truc tranquille
c'est une sorte de loyer
des 5 c'est ça se transforme en catalane
pour les blancs
tout ça c'est juste c'est juste catalan
c'est très solide
je reviens je reviens etc et là par
contre il peut c'est de la jouer donc
généralement
là pour laisser à son adversaire la
chance enfin le portique pour la jouer
mais non ma Kef mcnef de Nil il a pas
envie de se prendre la tête et il veut
il veut faire nul après le fait de
répéter la position c'est pas forcément
dire que
en fait dans un contexte comme celui-là
et qui a une grosse différence de niveau
entre entre mvl et lui et c'est normal
qu'un VL euh prennent sa chance pour
gagner et du coup ce qui se passe ce qui
se passe c'est qu'en fait un macnev même
si il veut la jouer
et ben je pense que tu vois c'est un peu
comme au poker tu vois c'est bluff quoi
il sait que noir vont la jouer il sait
que c'est pas à lui de faire un coin
inférieur pour faire la partie donc il
va laisser la mvl le faire et c'est bien
joué
peu importe ses ambitions
en gros il lui laisse quelque part le
l'initiative quoi en fait celui qui qui
veut changer regarde tu vois un bel F5
pour changer mais mvl ben ça a un coût
qui va sa responsable quoi au niveau là
tu vois c'est pas un coup que tu veux
faire de base mais tu le fais pour
déséquilibrer un petit peu tu le fais
pour essayer de gagner tu vois mais
c'est pas c'est pas aux blancs de
s'embêter à déséquilibrer la position
pour cette gagner parce que sur le
papier c'est quand même lui le moins
fort tu vois
et après voilà encore une fois genre
kazak comme le dit Kevin sur le chat
sont hyper hyper souplesse encore pas
mal de de d'exemples encore tout à
l'heure et
ici on sait pas moi j'ai pas la caméra
malheureusement sur macné on sait pas
quel âge il a peut-être c'est un jeune
talent aussi ce qui est quand même
beaucoup de de jeunes talents dans ce
tournoi
et mais en tout cas c'est clairement pas
à au blanc je pense de prendre le risque
et je pense que j'aurais fait la même tu
vois juste pour tilter Maxime en fait si
Maxime qui doit je pour gagner c'est pas
lui en fait tu vois et si il avait les
blancs Maxime à la place il aurait pas
joué F4 ou c'est un jusqu'à la mort quoi
tu vois il aurait trouvé un moment donné
le moyen de changer et voilà quoi
et c'est clair donc aucun intéressant
ok est-ce qu'on part un peu sur sur du
coup sur sur Jules voir ce qu'il fait
Jules allez carrément Jules
en plus les fedos CIF Moussa je pense
que nous sur chetcom on en a vu des
centaines centaines de parties comme ça
et en vrai je pense à adversaire qui
peut qui peut sourire à Jules parce que
sont très tactiques tous les deux et il
joue un petit peu si tu veux dans le
même style quoi tous les deux et donc
c'est une partie qui peut être très
sympa à regarder en tout cas petit derby
cheesecom
et Kevin qui est malade force à toi bon
courage bon rétablissement
ce qui a
donc
[Musique]
comment on passe tu vois j'ai bien aimé
le
noir qui empêchent l'expansion ici avec
P4 et qui est aussi prend la case à 4
parce qu'au final tu vois dans la parlé
le cavalier qui peut en Détroit pour
venir en E5 c'est cool si tu fais genre
cavalier A4 qui avait 5 cavaliers 3
cavalier 5 c'est un plan hyper
thématique dans cette position et là que
le pion A4 tu peux pas venir à 4 là il y
a sûrement tu vois une petite découverte
avec le
vis-à-vis tu vois du Fou donc Cavada
c'est pas possible donc le cavalier
vraiment bloqué sur la case C3 pour
l'instant alors pour l'instant oui mais
du coup pour sortir je peux passer par
vos deux cm mais je pense pas qu'il a
envie de faire ça mais en tout cas Jul
je pense que c'est pas la question de
savoir comment faire pour contrôler un
peu tout ça c'est pas évident de trouver
un coup
il y a aussi une idée qui est pas si
débile même si ça peut ça peut paraître
c'est fou P5
première idée c'est de jouer cavalier A4
elle est la même le même plan tu vois et
tu as aussi bien sûr des fois faut
prendre le 5 pour gagner la case de 5
qui est intéressant mvl il a fait deux
nulsé
c'est pas des tu vois c'est comme des
clients quoi c'est quand même des bons
joueurs et donc pour l'instant parcours
qui est qui est pas ok c'est pas non
plus c'est pas non plus incroyable quoi
tu vois c'est un petit peu décevant puis
espérer qu'il organise moins une mais
après c'est quand même des adversaires
qui sont costauds
et kobaf avec les Noirs à la première
partie bon tu vois c'est comme censé
être en favori mais il faut gagner c'est
clair mais après il y a quand même 13
rondes là il joue en 2005 en espérant
qu'il qui passe à 23 tu vois de Naka
aussi hein que que Maxime et il a aussi
deux points de nul donc ok c'est un peu
là souvent mais c'est pas encore fini je
pense
Maxime il est capable de de mettre en
marche la fusée et de partir à tout
moment
à trouver à trouver les coups ici à
fouet fin pour le cavalier ici parce que
cavalier on l'avait dit qu'en Détroit
RSA qui pourrait être pas mal mais c'est
pas simple de vraiment dans cette
pollution de prendre cette décision de
de jouer un plan qui fait 4 coups tu
vois c'est un peu long ouais mais après
toi le fou F1 qui profite des fois taper
sur le 6 c'est
intéressant moi j'aime bien faut faire
perso que j'aime pas parce qu'au final
quand le noir c'est un truc aussi un
jour de faire fouiller 8 fois 5 donc
voilà après avoir fait j'ai trois je
suis pas faim
et puis ce cavalier qui veut venir en 5
c'est quand même le but
ultime de se cavaler dans la pollution
quoi
d'ailleurs on le voit pas mal de temps
il choisit fout des trois ok donc il
prend la case du cavale
mais du coup il veut mettre la pression
je pense faire diagonale sur la pion
aussi éventuellement comment il continue
en fait son plan
dans cette pose Jack cavalier pas mal
car c'est pas une menace parce que puis
on prend le fou des fois encore les
cavalier mais à l'envers peut-être que
ça c'est une menace du coup faut prendre
il y a 5 à ce moment là
ça gagne un pion mais qui peut être
récupéré par la suite le pion le pion
des quatre j'en étais sur des quatre va
être attaqué pour l'instant non parce
qu'après prise presque avaler prend
large défend les plans des 4-3 fois et
j'ai quand même toujours en
intermédiaire qui me laisse un petit
tempo
donc ça pose quand même une question
réelle
[Musique]
au noir x 8 mais alors quand même ici
hyper logique parce que parce que ben il
défendent qu'un dessin avec les armes et
puis en plus il me l'actif sont fous sur
la diagonale donc je calme que de voir
ce qui va faire sur faux et 8
[Musique]
que j'aime pas
ouais je comprends ça va être pénible
comme ça pour les blancs ici mais faut
voir comment il va comment il va il va
jouer parce que là faut éviter si tu
veux tu pourras manger à 4 mais je crois
une fois je sens que tu peux pas manger
à Calpe sur cam fou prends là la dame
elle va être surchargée entre les deux
cavaliers
pas simple en tout cas tous les trois je
c'est un coup que j'aime pas trop trop
en pratique je trouve que c'est j'aurais
bien aimé parce que c'est attends c'est
pas ils sont là c'est quand même quelque
chose quelque chose assez normal quoi
pour ça que là d'ailleurs je vois
l'ordinateur qui propose de jouer de
jouer H3 sur sur X5 moi j'aime pas trop
au dessus être toujours à chaque fois
j'ai quatre quand à la colère ouverte tu
vois imaginons 3 fois H5 G4 qui va les
prendre E3 puis on prend même plus il
faut que j'ai 6 bah
donner la colonel les cases blanches
c'est pas un truc que tu as vraiment
envie de faire en fait dans cette
position c'est au trop ouvert en fait si
tu veux tu vois
[Musique]
c'est facile à jouer
mais il faut standard ok qu'est-ce qui
se passe chez MBA on peut la voir un
verre un petit peu voir
[Musique]
il a fait des progrès d'imposition ils
ont en tout cas c'est cool qu'il a qu'il
la joue ça me rendrait vraiment déçu de
voir le répétition mais bon c'était
évident qu'avec deux nul n'est pas
répéter faire nul sans jouer pour ces 7
donc c'est des positions vraiment avec
avantage
[Musique]
pour les blancs par rapport au casque un
procès à la structure mais
voir un peu ce qui se passe
tour C8 B4 ouais ce qui me parle parce
qu'elle fait des blancs très solide en
fait très scolaire une classe de 4 pour
pour les Noirs alors que les Blancs
jouent pour la minorité pour casser la
structure de noir
d'ailleurs souvent il y a du café de 4
G5 qui peut être un essai pour
[Musique]
pour un verre parce que bah ils font un
moment donné il faut qu'il envoie les
chevaux
faut prendre des décisions et puis
essayer de pas je demande d'améliorer sa
position
ouais donc faut pas trop tu vois là
l'idée que j'aimais bien l'idée de jouer
en fait il y avait B5 qui était pénis tu
vois pour affaiblir le pion ici pour en
fait casser sur des cinq d'ailleurs je
vais vous mettre si vous voulez la vue
du côté noir je suis désolé tu vois
c'est quand même mieux quand on voit du
côté mvl
après
il y a un plan assez intéressant pour
noir bon c'est position en fait on sait
que les blancs vont jouer avec avec
l'attaque de minorité vous savez à 4 bac
5 etc il y a un plan intéressant pour
mettre une pièce justement en C4 par
exemple là du coup je sais pas s'il
arrivera à temps mais par exemple un
jour mettre une pièce genre en C4 et
blindé avec B5
ça peut être intéressant donc certes on
donne la case C5 mais d'un autre côté
vous voyez que le pion qui est arriéré
en C6 ne sera plus faible parce que
j'aurais mis une pièce en C4
donc ça c'est intéressant mais la foulée
5 j'ai peur voici les portes B5 qui a
l'air de très très chiant
effectivement on n'a pas envie de jouer
fois si cela
mais tu vois juste pardon ouais sur B5
prise par exemple une prise je prends
ok
enfin même B5 prise jack aime ça en
l'air et je peux revenir avec mon fou
mais bon
justement ici Maxime il veut pas se
prendre des cinq c'est important et du
coup est-ce que mon coude est débile je
fous assise maintenant est-ce que c'est
stupide ou pas l'ordi n'aime pas du tout
ah mais je perd un pion ok enfin si je
mange de la dinde faire un pion parce
qu'il y a un clouage tu vois
tu penses que c'est une fourchette et
pas du tout en fait tu es cloué et tu
perds la pièce donc en fait tu ne peux
pas jouer ça
parce que si tu peux même une pièce en
C4 c'est quand même tu vois tu es ça et
tu joues B5 et en fait tu t'en sors bien
avec les Noirs mais là du coup c'est un
problème c'est un problème et là ici
après à 4 mais j'aime pas j'aime pas les
Noirs à moins qu'il a un truc un tour de
magie rapide avec un G5 qui est et qu'il
arrive à jouer à jouer rapidement
l'initiative à part ça et ben écoute je
vais pas faire
parce que B5 c'est quand même tu vois il
faut dire rapidement avec ça
c'est
ça me plaît pas
mais bon Maxime il est il a plein de
ressources
généralement c'est un genre qui veut
très vite mais beaucoup la pression en
temps que ce soit en blitz rapidement et
même d'ailleurs à partir il joue très
très vite mais là tu vois dans la partie
il y aurait 5 minutes à la parole contre
8 et ben ça se voit au final ça se voit
et que peut-être qu'il est pas en forme
dans ce tournoi parce que on voit bien
quand même que mvl généralement il y a
toujours sa petite 5 10 minutes d'avance
là il est il s'est mené autant contre un
joueur qui est moins fort que lui
et il y a quand même tenu là avant
champion du monde de Bliss non plus même
5 minutes pour lui
non bien sûr mais tu montres qu'il est
pas dans sa forme sa meilleure forme
parce que normalement enfin bon pour
tout le respect que j'ai pour les grands
maîtres à 2500 et l'autre tu vois MDL il
a
juste beaucoup plus fort en fait il joue
pas le même jeu et
en fait ben là même autant il est pas
bien la position il se fait un peu
marcher dessus tu as l'impression que ça
va tout le temps arriver tu vois il a un
problème sur fouguer ça donc cavalier
ici il a une bonne pièce en jeu c'est
celle-là et peut-être que maintenant B5
aura du C5 maintenant qu'il a réussi à
défendre les plans des cinq mais c'est
pas simple tu vois mais bon
tu sens que
même tu vois le calme rapide et le but
c'est quand même les cadence ou pour le
coup ils peuvent vraiment vraiment être
plus fort que l'adversaire quoi parce
qu'en barcelante bon ça fait un moment
qu'on qu'on savait qu'on on voit plus
trop trop
faire de bons résultats tu vois en
partie lente mais lui c'est rapide c'est
jamais pareil et puis c'est quand même
son quoi tu vois c'est là où il est plus
fort quoi
qu'il est plus trop trop
à son top à ça on la ressenti
là clairement ressenti
et mais les blancs
5 il y a des cadres F4 franchement moi
j'aime beaucoup les blancs j'aime
beaucoup ce que font les blancs
malheureusement ça me ça m'enchante pas
trop
c'est dur à laisser 5 hein
tu vois c'est trop affaiblissant qui va
repartir via F6 peut-être
mais bon là il empêche quelqu'un avait
le 5 et aussi une menace
internet ok ça j'ai pas trop trop fais
gaffe manger j'ai vu bien sûr les
speechers mais
après bon après ce petit chat quand même
qu'on dépose quand même pas mal
même s'il n'est pas bien tilt mais
ok ok il est moins il a un peu moins
[Musique]
chaud qu'avant quoi
après c'était période à moi je pense que
je sais que ça marche beaucoup de avec
des périodes et c'est pas sa période il
est il est pas
il est pas chaud alors j'ai 6
après tu vois il fait plein de trucs tu
vois tranquille
il va un peu toi améliorer et puis voir
un peu ce que follement que tu vois on
est quand même là au 26e coups et au
final les blancs ils ont fait que des
coups qui sont hyper facile tu vois il a
pas fait de tour de magie et qu'elle a
fait que des coups facile donc au final
tu te dis bon il va laisser jouer un
petit peu les blancs vas-y je joue des
coups de merde genre je joue un peu quoi
je te laisse jouer
tant mieux si ça peut lui permettre de
s'améliorer la position et puis en fait
il essaie de faire des coups solides qui
le compromettent pas quoi pour voir un
peu ce que les blancs font parce que tu
vois par exemple j'en sais rien mais les
blancs peuvent faire un blender par
exemple et te laisser faire ses cinq par
exemple tu vois
du coup je pense que c'est pas bête ce
qu'il fait tu vois il joue G6 moi j'ai 7
et tu vois les ils viennent de ça et ça
bon je sais pas ce que ça vaut mais
en tout cas
[Musique]
les blancs vont pas continuer à jouer
comme stockfish pendant toute la partie
et un moment donné si tu veux dès qu'il
va sentir votre app et ben
il pourra tenter un truc quoi c'est
bizarre tu vois donc
il y a un visa avec le roi
donc en mettant on l'a dit il a mis la
position il va jouer cavalier je suis
pas sûr quand même parce que il veut
quand même garder peut-être le C5
moi je verrai bien un roi 6 salaire
débile mais
wesh 6
c'est quoi c'est qu'en fait je m'enlève
du vis-à-vis et je vais faire 15 ans et
mon roi il est en sécurité en fait mon
roi bah mon roi il sera mis en H6 quand
j'essaie de quoi je suis tu vois là le
la potion noir elle est ouverte de
partout et puis si tu veux un moment
donné faire un truc il faut juste 5
jours et pour jeter 5 il faut tester en
H6 c'est une blague mais en fait pas que
c'est pas qu'une blague alors ouais il
est quand même plutôt
plutôt bien ici
et donc les français pour le tournoi il
y a justement mvl Jules Moussa et
Sébastien Mazet
et donc d'ailleurs Mazet s'appartient je
sais pas ce que ça donne actuellement
Mazo
on a vu la partie d'avant c'était pas
joli
le capitaine qui était pas dans ah il
s'est fait éclater pas sûr de pour
l'instant
on peut aller voir rapidement si vous
voulez
il a les Noirs Seb et une position sympa
j'aime bien ce cavalier 5 j'aime bien
aussi l'attaque qui peut avoir sur
le roi mais quand même il y a quand même
en dessin qu'un beau fond en B2
mais en tout cas j'aime bien sa position
en pratique
en rapide c'est sur une partie
ça fait un peu flipper d'avoir les
blancs ici tu vois il y a tout qui
rentre
pour vous dire pour la vérité
l'ordinateur il n'aime pas les Noirs
mais
ça peut faire flipper pour pour les
blancs mais bon je pense que du coup
sont trop dur à avoir en fait là je vois
des coups c'est juste un impossible quoi
juste qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
regarde là il dit l'ordi il faut deux
quoi
deux
F3 qui se regardent déjà j'étais
tranquille
et puis j'ai bah je prendrai trois enfin
en pratique c'est très très dur d'avoir
c'est juste un calculatrice quoi et puis
on est en pratique tu dis bon il va il
va manger là donc qu'est-ce que je fais
est-ce que je mange là mais quand tu
fais puis on prend tu dis ok il faut
prendre à rien et après il y a H3 et
après voilà en pratique tu vois ça tu te
dis trop dur tu vois et ça fait peur et
non je pense que moi je te vois très
très bien ici dans cette partie
il va la gagner
OK
est-ce que tu crois qu'on aille voir un
petit peu Jules voir ce qui se passe
c'est notre ami Jules allez hop
il va chercher son 3 sur 3
non je pense que tu as je pense que tu
as mis
qui a
j'arrive pas à avoir le message
c'est papine qu'il faut mettre Samia
ok donc du coup Jul il se passe quoi
Jules 3 4 5 il y a quand même trois
pions de plus pour Jules mais que des
pions faibles mais après on passait
quand même ça peut être une fusée ça
oui
pour lui mais encore une fois toi c'est
un joueur qui est très bon mais qui est
un petit peu Gumball tu vois et du coup
je pense que c'est un agent qui peut
clairement enfin il est pas pour moi il
est pas stable c'est capable de meilleur
comme du pire
et du coup pour juste je pense que c'est
ça peut être sympa vu qu'il est très
très chaud en ce moment là il s'est
passé plein de choses là c'est comme qui
peuvent encore chez moi il y a eu à 4 OK
on n'est pas la bonne position ok ça
avait changé non on n'est pas la bonne
position en fait il y a une pièce de
plus le fouet n'est pas un 4 ok ok ok
bon je retire ce que j'ai dit il est
foutu là ouais ok
ça évite les problèmes sur évidemment
[Musique]
F4 bien joué et il récupère après le
pion des 4
et là on voit que les cases blanches
quand même avec l'absence du foot classe
blanche c'est quand même des problèmes
pas simple
ah oui et puis et la fourchette ouais
mais bon ça après si il marche pas de
pion qui dit c'est pas grave
mais en fait
il est venu en T2 il s'est pris il faut
C3
je pense que mon plan était pas si con
au début je pensais que c'était mais ici
le coffret
faim et tu mets le cavalier E23
ça va pas mal ok on va on va partir sur
Maxime dommage ce qui se passe
et du coup on est ici on va remettre la
vue du côté noir et Maxime qui a réussi
à non je crois qu'il a pas le C5 je
crois que c'est il s'est pris B5 on va
regarder ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
et le pion à 4 qui peut être en faible
en fin de en fin de compte faire
attention à tout ça tout à renforcer
obligé de le protéger et maintenant je
me lasse de rentrer la tour en C2 bah
écoute Maxime tu vois qui a tricoté
tricoté tricoté et qu'elle laisse
l'adversaire un petit peu faire des
courants d'hommes et ça se sentir bon
pour pour lui ça commence à être pas mal
parce que là la colonne c'est maintenant
tu as grâce à fou d'essai en fait enfin
grâce à foot et si c'est ben il a il a
provoqué toi qui me permet de pouvoir
remettre les tours en voiture la colonne
C c'est hyper bien joué de sa part parce
que surtout ici
ben je peux juste manger une fois
peut-être il y a quand même à chaque
fois tu vois si pour la tour il part à
deux et s'il prend un cavalier prendre
un Caval il faut voir ce qui se passe
l'autre cavalier pour voir mais
mais là du coup il y a quand même
beaucoup de jeux pour pour lui du coup
grâce à justement un peu passif de son
adversaire
il a pu ok donc ça commence à quand même
cette très positif pour lui du coup
d'ailleurs j'aime bien aussi un petit
plan sympa pour Maxime si jamais les
blancs venaient à mettre une tour ancien
ce qui m'a l'air assez logique au final
parce que notamment mes devoirs c'est un
jour de faire cavalier des deux cavalier
C4 et mettre l'autre cavalier
je passe c'est possible de faire ça mais
ça peut être sympa en tout cas tous les
cinq prises ok il veut taper sur sur la
cavale
fou ici ok attention
ça peut partir faire attention
et
[Musique]
reparti en arrière je pense qu'on a des
problèmes de coups
[Musique]
mais là l'ordi enfin si tu veux la
récupérer
petit problème de connexion avec lescom
tour des deux et là on va voir sûrement
4 je sais pas lequel
mais celui-là fait attention car vos
pions c'est chaud
l'autre qui arrive quand et si jamais ça
position tu vois si les blancs c'est que
tellement facile tellement celui de la
structure
c'est pas facile mais ok tactiquement
j'ai quand même deux colonnes de 23
colonne C je peux toujours rentrer avec
ma tour à un moment donné hein puis il
peut y avoir des choses quoi mais bon ok
moi j'ai confiance j'ai confiance
une minute à la pendule et puis bon ben
à ce niveau là ça risque à un moment
donné de choses
tu regardes la cavalier 2 j'ai cavaler
prendre pour prendre et Tours C3 qui va
gagner le cavalier
qu'elle va les prendre des 5 bah ça perd
une pièce
oui tout simplement attends
ou pas
je pense
à toi ok
3 mais c'est la partie et là j'attaque à
la fois ça et ça il va avoir 6 un des
deux on peut imaginer et enfin
du coup peut-être aussi hein pourquoi
pas
être bloqué sur la 6e mais bon voilà je
suis c'est pas mal
et là du coup ben tu bouges le roi et tu
as ça en l'air et ça en l'air
et je crois que tu peux pas
faire autrement tu joues enfin ça marche
pas dans ma douche je prends juste là
non
c'est quoi le
genre je pense tout le temps Maxime il a
raison
il prend son temps peut-être regarder
des trucs avec des cavaliers 5 je sais
pas moi c'est trouver des idées mais là
je vois même pas du tout comment tu peux
arnaquer quoi
parce que là
je crois qu'il y a rien mais sinon
directement cavalier prend prends des 5
dame prend des cinq et puis directement
pour prendre des trois en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a une pièce là ici
je pense en plus on a même pas l'ordi
vous voyez que
de partout on est malheureusement abusé
de te de réfléchir avec notre cerveau et
ça c'est pas facile
mais du coup je pense que c'est une
pièce ça m'a l'air ça m'a l'air perdu et
Maxime qui va qui va mettre la fusée en
mars qui marque son premier point ça
fera quand même de nul une victoire ça
va être deux sur trois et bah c'est le
début cavaluer 5 waouh
alors attends
je pense que
s il y a des découvertes
il y a forcément il y aura forcément
et faire attention j'ai même être mon
mec mon four en dessin que ce serait ce
serait cool
mais
ça c'est une bonne blague
en 2500 en fait contre contre VL ça ça
semble
en fait il faisait rien mais il faisait
tu vois et au final
en fait je te laisse faire des coups je
joue montre-moi un peu que tu vas gagner
quoi tu vois et en fait quand tu écoutes
tu fais plein plein d'erreurs tu vois
après 6 ans chaque fois et en fait tu
vois clairement que bah que des mecs tu
connais même jeu quoi et tiens mais le
fait de laisser l'adversaire par défaut
je trouve ça génial ça en fait plus tu
es fort plus tu arrives à le faire parce
que nous même nous notre niveau on
n'arrive pas à le faire ça tu vois nous
on veut plus concret on va se faire des
trucs mais là clairement
mdr il a fait marche il a fait parler la
la l'expérience quoi dans cette partie
parce qu'il a essayé mais en vrai il a
pas fait une très bonne partie un
maximum tu vois mais il a joué et
l'adversaire doit jouer
déjà il a juste joué solide et
la partie améliorer sa pause mais la
partie on peut on peut pas dire que
c'était vraiment une une
très belle partie de Maxime tu vois mais
c'est une partie je veux l'expérience et
je trouve que c'est assez gagné
en plus malheureusement pour lui les
pions sont sur cases enfin fondament
sans carte blanche avec le foodcasse
blanche donc ça veut dire que même si je
parais trois pions c'est gagné alors que
ça aurait été un foodcas noir ça aurait
été nul donc là du coup c'est super dur
en fait c'est perdu on va pas tarder sur
cette partie là malheureusement
qu'est-ce que vous faites le capitaine
Mazet
donc là il y a quand même une qualité de
plus pour pour maso avec le roi blanc
qui qui est bien bien
[Musique]
F5 OK et bah écoute je récupère j'aime
bien les blancs en fait peut-être
faut voir parce que long du jeu mais le
roi blanc a pas mal de cases non plus
faudrait réussir en fait je me dis que
sur le long terme si on change les dames
un jour peut-être que je peux arriver à
jeb6 et à te poser un problème mais bon
est-ce que dame B2 pour les Noirs c'est
un coup jouable ici
je me lasse quoi
pour moi le fou défendait ok ça menace
maths il y a au moins échec échec ça
marche pas du tout en fait ah oui oui il
y a trop d'échec
tu sens que ta dame doit rester là quoi
ça tu le sens
et généralement quand un homme d'âge
matériel il faut changer les pièces tu
vois genre
la théorie de ce qu'il va faire quand tu
gagnes c'est le bon coup mais là en fait
tu vois qu'au final avec un plein de
planches et les blancs tu as un pion
arrière en DS avec un vis-à-vis et un
clouage tu vois qui a le sein qui peut
arriver à tout moment puis imbé 6 et au
final tu as pas forcément
c'est ça bon
B3 donc B6 le frigo quand je serai prêt
mais c'est pas simple en fait tu vois
c'est pas simple du tout à évaluer de
pollution est-ce que les noirs sont
mieux est-ce que tu vois et donc
vraiment à voir on peut dire que je
bouge ma tour je perdais sur échec
donc à évaluer c'est pas simple
d'ailleurs je me lâche pas en compte que
moi je me suis complètement trompé dans
l'évaluation de ma position parce que
bon moi je peux déclare
mais au final
apparemment
pour C3 j'arrive avant en fait mais
c'est pas simple évaluer tu vois cette
position c'était assez compliqué
et qui a gagné qui t'avait dit son
hippopotame
qui a gagné on n'a pas vu la partie du
tout alors attends
[Musique]
une autre partie à avoir on peut aller
voir un petit je regarde c'est un truc
intéressant
ah j'ai pu j'ai pu le parti mot de mon
côté alors attends comment ça se fait
le champion du monde champion du monde
c'est abdos je vais vous changer la cam
je vais mettre la mixe
j'aime pas du tout c'est
un truc qui met là sur Obs entre les
entre les les
scènes là les transitions transportables
donc F4 qui est donc là le champion du
monde nordiberg theov qui allait blanc
et qui va qui va à priori gagner parce
qu'il va manger F7 en force il a une
qualité puis en plus
ça a l'air ça a l'air fini et
[Musique]
est-ce que tu penses que que
notre liberté
du monde
franchement tout est possible en réalité
après évidemment que j'aimerais bien
voir
évidemment que j'aimerais bien voir
un mvl prend sa place par exemple tu
vois mais moi je verrai bien un petit
maso j'ai entendu le monde ce serait
beau aussi en réalité hein
non non en vrai en vrai moi je pense
qu'il a 0 % de faire un champion du
monde avec il est très fort très
talentueux mais bon déjà il a fait
pendant sa ville et ma mère là je pense
que c'est beaucoup trop
beaucoup trop dur là s'abandon prochain
coup abandon ah oui imparable
moi je pense qu'il a sorti non mais dans
les prétendants
mais tu as aussi même le
ericasit on en a parlé de l'Indien qui
était qui était assez chaud et reghazi
en partie rapide franchement c'est pas
déconnant moi je pense que
il est capable de faire un truc comme ça
alors bonne soirée c'est un jour que
j'aime vraiment beaucoup de Forest
qui est ici qui est noir c'est un joueur
qui est très très
comment dire
hyper préparé plein d'idées est très
originale comme comme joueur et j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup c'est parti
généralement donc là il a un petit peu
en difficulté avec avec les noirs et qui
est une main il y a trois papillons
passés ici mais attention que lui aussi
il va vite avec et c'est pas simple de
jouer avec B3 B3 d'ailleurs comment
comment on empêche
en fait je pense qu'il faut pousser des
plus rapidement mais
[Musique]
mais non en fait j'ai trop dur quoi
juste trop dur
ah mais il y a un vélo le matin il y a
un réseau de maths
du coup il a fait trois qui qui empêche
le 6 du coup mais qui fait quand même 6
en gros ça empêche heureusement que tu
veux tu vois ça empêche pas tout ça mais
il y a quand même il y a quand même
il y a quand même
plus le match vous prend ton renforcé
de base je sais pas
ça c'est juste perdu complet donc la
caméra on a la partie de
de
guéri on va aller voir si vous voulez
ce qui nous fait
direct en don chenco donc un joueur très
imprévisible capable de tout
claque plus pour pour guérir
de plus avec le pion qui va tomber mais
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est si
facilement gagnant que ça
pas si simple parce qu'il y a toujours
ce fou deux qui est attaqué
tranquillement genre cavalier bouge
il y a peut-être du G4 d'ailleurs moi
j'ai quatre je passe sur par contre
c'est un peu fixer la position je suis
pas sûr que ça soit
une bonne chose
je suis pas sûr voilà attendre c'est
bien
et quand le roi n'a pas tirer ici à un
moment juste défendre puis ses cavaliers
par pour manger les pions je prendrai
lui
et c'est pas simple de gagner ça avec
les Noirs je suis même pas sûr que cette
position soit gagnable en fait
là pour l'instant ça a l'air totalement
totalement le nul à première vue et
encore une fois encore une fois on l'a
vu sur la partie de la deuxième ronde
que une position nulle
peut se retourner totalement à la partie
justement de Forest
son adversaire là qui
qui s'est fait complètement retourné
vraiment dans en fait mais c'est tout ça
rien touche à rien en fait
là maintenant voilà peut-être
et attendre en fait parce que tu fais
quoi du coup parce que si les Noirs
vraiment décident de d'aller manger le
Piona je sacrifierai mon fou enfin je
mangerai ici pour que tu mangeras là-bas
et après je piquerai lui et je
sacrifierai mon foot sur ton pion quoi
en vrai je vois pas de plan bien pour
moi ça gagne pas quoi G2 ok il évite les
échecs les fourchettes etc il va manger
là par contre un peu dommage quand même
ranger deux parce que du coup tu perds
un temps pour faire voyager 4 ok
remarque donc
peut-être et en gros le jour où tu fais
cavaler là maintenant je mange là et du
coup mon roi sera prêt pour aller manger
ici mais je peux même manger là
peut-être aussi mais je préfère quand
même
pour pour les noirs de fer promotion
avec le pion le pion a normalement ouais
normalement ça gagne pas ouais
il fait des couples
[Musique]
je comprends pas trop
il y avait cavalier 3 avec ça c'était
clair là du coup ben on attend kb6 ça va
être ça va être le coup maintenant qu'il
a joué le cavalier en C4 soit il
retourne à la maison pour défendre le
pion F5 soit il joue il joue qu'avait
les bêtises en décision tu veux pas peux
pas tout défendre et guéri qui réfléchit
beaucoup et qui qui va qui va prendre le
pion à 4 tu as le choix de toute façon
du coup tu prends F5 mais cette finale
peut des fois gagner pour les Noirs tu
sais si tu arrives en fait à faire un
bouclier avec ton cavalier mais avoir
genre imaginons un truc con mais je mets
mon roi là je mets un cavalier ici et je
pousse tu vois et tu peux pas avec ton
fou venir manger le pion en fait mais
bon c'est dur à mettre en place et bon
[Musique]
tu as le roi en fait il est parti en F2
ce qui me paraît un peu bizarre en fait
au final parce que maintenant je suis un
peu loin du pionget tu vois j'ai
l'impression qu'il a perdu un petit peu
un petit peu du temps un temps en entier
parce que là tu vois si j'étais là je
préfère ça prochain coup manger puis
après je te mets mon fou et j'essaie de
trouver un truc mais bon
parce que moi tu vois si le fait que
j'ai un contre-jour avec ce petit pion
quand même mais là mon roi est loin tu
vois j'ai pas beaucoup de temps c'est ça
1 2 3 4 coups avant de pouvoir libérer
l'espace pour pour envoyer le pionger
c'est peut-être un petit peu long c'est
ça du coup ce qui va vouloir faire je
pense c'est ramener le roi peut-être par
ici mais pendant que tu as ça je vais
aller manger l'autre pion avec mon roi
et mon cavale en vrai ça me fait un peu
peur
[Musique]
il faut que tu mettes ton roi ici et là
du coup hop ah oui et puis là c'est fini
[Musique]
il a raté ça
il a raté ça guéri en même temps plus
trop de temps à la pendule ça commence
facile parce que prise vapoint c'est
fini et là c'est un terminal terminal à
4 et tu veux plus empêcher le pion ok
belle technique
je
sais pas je n'étais pas sûr d'avoir ce
que c'était vraiment terminé cette
tunnel
en tout cas je sais pas je joue
en fait j'ai pas de coup pour attendre
en fait
à la fourchette et sur ça qui s'est
passé
je suis
c'est gagnant facile ça
apparemment c'est une façon
en pratique j'aurais
sûrement jouer un truc comme ça faut
bien que j'ai pas de cahier tranquille
il va arriver
[Musique]
et a priori il est gagnant il est
gagnant facile c'est quand même facile
parce que le roi noir encore une fois
l'activité du roi c'est important et là
il est actif avec son roi le pion une
casa d'âme il fait rien du tout la tour
doit rester là pour défendre ce pion
c'est ça les deux pions
[Musique]
tout simplement c'est ça cette termine à
doigt ok donc ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle encore une fois il y a juste ce
qui s'est passé comment la partie parce
que moi ça me va pas clair à la base
cette finale là
attends on en était par là j'ai un peu
vite pour arriver à la position qu'on
avait
on a été ici voilà là je crois G7 avait
des finales maso faut pas lui faire tour
à trois
ok le fou qui part en C8 mais au final
il va finir par sacrifier la tension
bizarre le choix de Burkina
parce qu'en fait ouais je vais toujours
réussir à manger et puis j'ai le
meilleur final la pure H4 il tu le Game
parce qu'en fait le plus rapide et il
empêche il a tous les pions sont faits
tous les pions blancs sont bloqués là
c'est évident que les noirs sont
beaucoup mieux et Mazo en finale c'est
quand même une référence pour le coup
c'est je pense la partie du jeu qui
comprend le mieux
il a juste beaucoup mieux compris la
finale
c'est impressionnant de voir quand même
la technique des fois
en finale en finale Mazo il est il est
vraiment très important
là c'est une leçon c'est vraiment une
leçon je suis un peu vite pour voir mais
vraiment
tu vois la priorité au niveau des
fonctions
[Musique]
c'est une belle ronde là pour les
joueurs français
donc c'est cool c'est ça et du coup du
coup bah écoute on a Mazet qui revient à
deux points sur trois mvl qui vient
aussi à 23
Jules qui vient de perdre donc il reste
aussi à 23 2 sur 3 ouais c'est donc sont
tous à 203 avoir un peu ce qui se passe
voir si on a un petit un petit duel maso
mvl ça pourrait être ça pourrait être
drôle ça va être les deux venez d'avoir
les Noirs par contre Moussard et les
couleurs à voir
et sinon après il y a un plus grand
monde un covalaire qui est le britchouc
ça joue encore ou pas
[Musique]
le
premier adversaire de mvl sur la
première roue
après le plus grand chose il y a des
gens qu'on ne connaît pas enfin quad
c'est pas encore actualisé par tiascom
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait notre minimal il
avait un mm sur deux
il est où notre animal ça m'intéresse
[Musique]
il est complètement fou
je l'ai vu en un tournoi complètement
taré
le toit on va mettre à 25 40
et OK
donc on a qui encore à 330
que on a guéri du coup on a artemie
et on a 3 sur 3 on a encore Douda on a
fait deux séances
et je crois que c'est tout donc là on va
voir déjà des des gros gros chocs pour
pour la home 4 du coup
on va commencer à avoir un petit peu le
la suite se dessiner bon déjà là les
parties enfin les les
appariements tu vois c'est déjà quand
même assez fort quand tu as fait dossier
Moussa c'est quand même pas des
[Musique]
du monde
regazi alors depuis le début je dis que
lui je le vois bien en fait
il est il est hyper impressionnant même
on l'a vu d'ailleurs son match contre
carwana hospitches où il a perdu
ambulette
c'est incroyable encore une fois contre
toute attente mais mais en vrai il
regazie et reghazi pour moi c'est c'est
un joueur qui
qui est tout avec capable d'être
champion du monde
en fait il est vraiment en forme
et que le tableau de souris c'est un
joueur qui peut faire la surprise après
bien sûr il est pas favori hein pour
être champion du monde ça c'est clair
mais tu vois il a vraiment un style
efficace il joue vite et
jamais à l'abri de surprise et en tout
cas pour l'instant il fait il fait un
début de tournoi parfait donc
qui a battu pour l'instant
kadrix bon en 2006 pure Annick et la
demschenko donc 3 sur 3 et lui aussi il
a un style vraiment vraiment efficace le
doubler en plus là c'est c'est un temps
là qui se déroule
mais bon le doublé ça pourrait être un
ouf Jack l'année dernière quand même
bien surpris lors de ce championnat du
monde en plus le départage avec avec
comment il s'appelle un épaule
n'est pas on fait de la peine
mais
en vrai trop content pour être heureux
parce que en vrai il en veut trop quoi
tu vois toujours hyper sérieux moi je
l'ai vu même c'est con mais le match le
speech tu voyais en fait il était
tellement propre sur lui en fait tu as
l'impression que le mec je sais pas
comment dire mais il a la classe quoi
franchement elle a besoin
je suis impressionné par les jeunes par
les jeunes de ce niveau là c'est mais tu
as mes parents
aussi il était là il a vu il avait
commencé avec un star de ouf je sais pas
ce qu'il a fait mais il a un truc genre
8 sur 8 un truc comme ça
à la fin bon et après il perd contre
karassen contre etc ce qui est au final
un petit peu normal mais
tu vois juste
il est tout le temps en fait tu vois il
est pas il est sorti un peu de nulle
part il a fait champion olympique avec
son équipe
il a fait champion du monde en rapide
et puis
[Musique]
championnat de du monde de Fischer
random il était là il a fait quand même
quatrième il me semble parce qu'il est
dans il allait en demi et il a perdu
l'eau demi et le match il me semble
qu'on soit 47 je crois qu'il a et après
il a perdu contre 45
pour le dernier match il me semble je
sais pas de bêtises donc mais tu vois
dans tous les tournois d'élite et ben en
fait il est là quoi il est là et puis ça
m'est ridicule il est toujours dans les
premières enfin je les rôles de devant
quoi et je trouve que bah c'est un
poisson le mec il a 17 ans quoi
la dernière tu connaissais pas quoi tu
vois
[Musique]
donc c'est c'est quelqu'un qui va c'est
un jeune qui va qui va aller loin pour
la suite franchement tu as
une génération qui arrive là qui est
juste monstrueuse entre Sarine entre
entre
entreigi entre Bercy Rohff enfin tous
les Indiens en fait surtout entre une
majorité d'Indiens et 12 becs et de
kazak en fait tu vois l'Asie niveau
échec c'est comment ça va être
clairement le futur tu vois il y a pas
trop de même tu vois à l'époque c'était
des Russes tu avais les casse pas un
flecarpone
les Russes ils sont un petit peu
tu vois il y a des pots ok mais en jeûne
la relève ta qui a scenico
il y a deux ans il y avait le même élo
et il avait 27 30 un truc comme ça là
bon il fait plus grand chose en tout cas
on a un petit peu
trop parler de ces Penko tu as aussi
artemière mais bon bah maintenant il a
trois quatre ans bah oui c'était les
jeunes mais au final ils ont rien fait
en trois quatre ans tu vois et donc au
final ben écoute tu vois il y avait un
chinois il y avait comment il s'appelle
[Musique]
2730 et l'eau je crois un truc comme ça
à 16 ans
et maintenant je crois que là je suis là
mais la vingtaine
exactement
mais en fait si tu veux c'est difficile
de
confirmer en fait à ce niveau-là les
mecs ont tous tellement fort que chaque
dizaine si tu veux de points et l'eau
c'est un travail monstre en fait la
différence après tu vois par exemple
titre je crois que c'était au candidat
si je dis pas de bêtises non peut-être
je me trompe en tout cas il a quand même
battu Carson c'était pas les candidats
parce que
c'est ça
[Musique]
encore une fois c'est un super joueur
mais tu vois les trois cafés
bien sûr c'est un excellent joueur mais
comparé à d'autres qui montent tu vois
et réghasi chaque point qui fait et ben
tu as parlé lui quoi tu vois pareil pour
abuser pareil pour Sarine enfin ça rime
plus trop d'ailleurs mais à part sur
internet ça arrive pour l'instant pauvre
bof mais tu vois en fait c'est ça alors
que lui il a fait un montant oui il a
battu 47
faire une bonne partie car elle scène
après il veut pas tout le monde donc
après prendre des risques un petit peu
démesuré mais en fait
tu as qui vraiment
en nouvelle espoir tu vois que que tu
entends tout le temps quoi genre tu vois
franchement et si Benko ben moi ça fait
longtemps que je pense que je porte
[Musique]
ça remonte déjà
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait depuis ce
temps-là tu vois en fait c'est vrai
est-ce que c'est qualifié au speechers
est-ce qu'il y a fait un truc non tiens
par contre tu vois les regazies les
gooches les mêmes praganda qu'un jeu
tous les les tournois de caracène
etc c'est des mecs qui sont en train de
confirmer tu vois en 2007 quoi et
du coup il t'a pas avant de relève russe
ou quoi tu vois j'ai vu dans le temps il
y a une résine volodar c'est aussi un
point est là bah il est là il a deux
points il a 25 60 il a il a battu en
2100 la ronde un et après il a fait nul
en tomates 80 et une nulle chez
paris-nov donc c'est bien mais bon voilà
16 ans quoi
c'est très très bien à 25 60 à 16 ans en
15 ans mais pour être top top regarde à
16 ans on vous cache qu'il a 27 30 quoi
et t'as pas vraiment de relève dans même
en Russie alors qu'à l'époque c'était la
Russie qui écrasait tout le monde mais
là maintenant c'est la grande école
c'est ça au fur et à mesure là tu as
l'Asie qui commence complètement à
raser tout le monde l'Asie entre les
Indiens les Ouzbeks les Kazakhs même les
Chinois
c'est
plaisir Amiens aussi j'oubliais je dis
ça mais aussi c'est fort
de base
même sans lui était forte parce que ils
ont mcdoslo ils ont
une amie pour rien enfin pas mal de
joueurs talentueux à 2007 et en vrai
c'est c'est
[Musique]
chaud quoi
l'été dernier il a passé tous l'été à
enchaîner plein de tournants en Espagne
il a pas fait le temps très très fort
tu vois mais oui il est souvent dans les
trois premiers éloins à chaque fois et
il faisait en moyenne
aller entre 7 et demi et 8 sur 9 à
chaque fois
ouais donc c'est déjà des
monstrueux quand tu joues cette musique
cette émission 9 ou 809 rue Moyenne à
2005 2006
à un moment donné bon tu vois et il fait
ça à chaque fois tu veux à chaque
endroit chaque partie et du coup
après il a pas encore confirmé si tu
veux Google je pourrais faire un tournoi
avec lui ou ben effectivement il joue
contre Karat zen une époque en lent etc
et là on va voir un peu
mais après en tout cas c'est cool si tu
veux
score des Français voulaient je peux
vous les mettre si vous voulez français
après là je crois que pour cette
troisième ronde là d'après ce que je
vois toutes les parties sont terminées
on attend la pareillement de la
quatrième ronde
mais ce que je veux dire en fait c'est
que je vais faire je peux vous le mettre
sur le côté dans le stream si vous
voulez
attendre secondaire
si moi je vais me remettre sur le
ici
OK et du coup attends
je vais vous les mettre si vous voulez
être gentil avec vous ça c'est vraiment
parce que si vous les gars alors les
appareils
sont pas pas sortis sur chaise comme ça
ça arrive après est-ce qu'ils sont
sortis ou pas sur place
ou belle affiche ok mvl qui joue contre
Archa c'est une je crois que c'est une
fille il me semble
ah non pardon je dis maintenant
excusez-moi vous avez entendu on va
couper ce
passage twitch t'inquiète merci
[Rires]
nonienne
seconde quand j'ai dit que c'est une
fille je me suis dit qu'il y a quelqu'un
à un championnat féminin parallèle mais
c'est ça
en fait non c'est Arica et Archa j'ai
mélangé les deux je suis désolé
du coup du coup non je pense que les
gars après on va suivre on va suivre
caracen ça vous fait pas de problème il
y a Mazet qui joue du bof intéressant
ouais ça va être intéressant
26 c'est cool
mvl il joue du coup un 25-70 ce qui est
bien aussi mais c'est vrai que là
quintzen donc le numéro 1 mondial le
champion du monde est parti classiques
triple vainqueur du champion du monde
partir rapide et triple ou quadruple je
suis pas sûr de Blitz qui joue contre le
champion du monde en titre de Partie
Rapide App Store franchement pour moi
c'est une affiche de ouf et en vrai j'ai
plus envie de suivre ça je vais vous
mettre le score j'ai oublié de le faire
regardez ça le score des Français si
vous voulez
pour que vous puissiez puissiez le voir
hop
je tiens avec vous quand même
je vais vous mettre quand même en mode
studio on va être gentil
en tout cas bienvenue à toutes celles et
ceux qui nous rejoignent là on va
attaquer justement la quatrième ronde
sur les 5 de ce premier jour de tournoi
pour aujourd'hui
et un et demi et deux et deux pour pour
ml aussi de nul et une win
c'est ça hop je vous le mets un tout
petit
je peux vous le mettre là peut-être
je sais pas trop le mettre faut pas que
ça fasse trop moche
ou je le mets en dessous
comme ça
OK
est-ce que ça vous convient ce que j'ai
fait là le petit montage avec le texte
là
c'est un truc simple
un bel va jouer là dans quelques minutes
il y a quelques
[Musique]
messages de Tata Marcel qui va dégager
tout de suite à Marseille
hop là ciao
j'ai pas le j'avais pas l'autorisation
donc non non mais je l'avais pas vu mais
c'est juste tu me dis si tu as si tu as
des fois je rate des choses donc si tu
le vois des trucs comme ça juste
tu me tu me dis pas de souci et parce
que des gens comme ça voilà c'est si
c'est vite vu bah oui
professionnel ce que tu as fait
magnifique ouais j'ai mis le truc ça
vous va ou pas là
[Musique]
la le texte que j'ai mis en dessous là
je pense ça fait pas mal j'ai pas voulu
trop empiéter sur le truc nickel au
monde on a le score de tous les Français
pour l'instant donc c'est
nickel ouais du coup du coup ok donc la
2e 3 4 5 3 sur 3 et là ça va reprendre
dans combien de temps d'ailleurs
normalement la route 4 a 13h45 mais il
est déjà 14h19
[Musique]
dans tous les cas ouais il y a toujours
un peu de retard en fait parce que quand
en pratique il y a toujours des gens qui
finissent un peu tard
etc donc
c'est c'est
c'est toujours assez c'est normal en
fait c'est des parties incréments donc
forcément forcément elle est partie qui
peut durer plus longtemps que prévu
en pratique il y a toujours des petites
des petits
des petits problèmes ou des choses qui
font pas un peu de temps et cumulés au
final moi je le sais parce que même moi
tu vois je vais regarder pas mal de
tournois tu vois avec plusieurs Asos
quoi tu vois
et au final tu peux faire ce que tu veux
au niveau des horaires
extrêmement dur de de garder ses
horaires tu as toujours des problèmes
des événements de cette ampleur là ou
même pas
non mais même le rapide du coin tu dis
ouais c'est bon
toujours des trucs tu as toujours tu as
toujours des problèmes quoi tu vois mais
là c'est vrai
il y a quand même 80 parties enfin 90
parties qui sont retransmises en direct
tu as des caméras de partout enfin c'est
c'est pas c'est pas évident tu vois et
donc pour comprendre qu'il y a un peu de
retard après c'est une demi-heure
c'est beaucoup mais à la fois c'est pas
une énorme que ça parce que bon
tu vois et des fois ça peut être de la
faute de l'organe des fois des fois pas
parce que des fois il y a des parties
qui sont longues et les organes te
propose une pause imaginons toi tu viens
de faire une heure de partie ou une
heure et une partie pour pour
ta partie quoi et disons les gars on
enchaîne direct parce que parce qu'on
est en retard quoi attends mec la
semaine pause quoi cinq minutes quoi tu
vois et du coup c'est un petit peu ça
l'idée
et merci beaucoup tout en haut pour le
pour le prime merci à toi bien vu tout
en haut
ça se déroule
ou pas normalement il est pas là sinon
on aurait mis son score aussi
aussi dans le chat c'est presque envie
aussi de mettre le score de Fatou mais
[Rires]
c'est vrai qu'elle va commencer sa
première partie c'est ouais c'est
aujourd'hui que ça commence son tournoi
non OK dans l'après-midi je pense il y a
une partie ou deux
je sais pas généralement tu as 7 9 roues
sur quatre jours c'est du 2 2 2 2 2
mais la ronde un c'est jamais claire
c'est un ou deux je pense que c'est il y
a une ronde généralement pour le premier
jour mais après je sais pas il faut
regarder
et on sait pas pourquoi pourquoi firou
n'est pas présent pourquoi il est pas là
on sait pas juste qu'il a pas envie je
pense que ça quoi
j'ai hâte de voir justement la partie de
Mazet un compte de boxe
classique alors que de bof il est
toujours très original dans les dans
danser dans ses ouvertures dans ces
choix et d'ailleurs c'est pas pour rien
que du bof il a travaillé aussi avec 45
dans les dans le championnats du monde
etc un des seconds de cartienne parce
qu'il y a toujours plein d'idées
d'ouverture il y a une culture
égyptienne très très bonne et
intéressé par ce profil
dans son équipe
franchement si moi je devais jouer si
moi je veux un tournant d'échec et
choisir un préparateur enfin ou un mec
pour être dans mon équipe en vrai moi je
choisirais sûrement un mec comme vent de
Forest voilà
ça se ça se voit mais il est trop il a
dans toutes les ouvertures il a des
idées quoi il y a des idées de ouf à
chaque fois j'adore c'est
tu as l'impression que au niveau des
échecs qui ils te prends toutes les
lignes qui sont dites mauvaises réfutés
ou quoi et il va te les bosser comme un
comme un [ __ ] excusez-moi du terme
mais et il va il va la jouer quoi et en
fait c'est chaud quoi j'adore j'adore
c'est vraiment un joueur que j'apprécie
beaucoup
des années en top en Top 12 des Top 16
d'ailleurs tu l'as déjà rencontré IRL ou
pas mais moi je le connais pas mais
c'est un très bon ami de Barbie par
exemple Barbie
et tout
le cagnotte ah bah tiens écoute Cyril
super idée
de me coacher
une question qui demandait quand est-ce
que commencer la quatrième ronde ça
aurait commencé dans quelques dans
quelques minutes secondes les joueurs
commencent à s'installer tranquillement
l'envoi des autres qui prend place là
derrière le mec qui prend des photos en
premier plan les filles on a je crois
que c'est Bastia suivi avec les Blancs
pas de bêtises contre eux avec les Noirs
comment elle s'appelle déjà noir c'est
une Russe
j'ai un trou de mémoire je peux pas vous
dire comment il s'appelle
mais c'est une loi d'ailleurs qui a joué
dans l'équipe de blitstream lors de lors
de comment ça s'appelle ce tournoi déjà
[Musique]